c'est le temps juste que je fasse le
truc technique à
à la chante là la chante la chante là il
ya des cités qui va arriver
est-ce qu'on soirée ce petit débrief hab
débriefer voilà c'est le monde eu des
bruits je pense du coup on va débriefer
tranquillement est-ce que je te mets je
le remet sur cette can
facile alors de s'en souvenir de leur
toiture du coup est ce que ça fonctionne
ouais bon alors ce petit débrief ah ben
on a bien fait de se le garder sous le
coude
donc est ce que vous avez pensé de ce
casse tournant pendant cette coupe du
monde
si pour rebondir sur ton souhait sur
twitter m voilà on va les laisser
c'était cool fait des trucs à revoir à
mieux faire
oui c'est qu'on ait une cam sur un champ
clos baisse parfois ça allait jouer je
sais pas combien je je les ai vus jouer
chez peu plus à mal en fait tu sais qui
assure enfin on aura un délai et à
vraiment 20 à 30 secondes de décalage
entre le moment où il joue et à et le
mental cookies par o hougaard - sa femme
extraordinaire et caméra bouge personne
qui m'a fixe il est très concentré quoi
pour il me demande qu'est ce qui a fait
comme si tu fais sa coiffe abbaoui
s'égrènent je ferais mettre en place des
sanctions contre les vallées il fait
quoi mvl ça peut il vraiment le chat ray
non mais ça n'est point quoi la pierre
régis que jamais vu à l'extraordinaire
eyes dans un beau budget pourtant way
en millions je pense ouais c'est beau on
va voir je pense aller moi je veux un
pronom un ennemi 1/2 pour à carnac un
petit nul dans celle-là et huit ans
après
après j'ai une question de kfc plus
relatif à son suivi après il peut pas
revoir les règles du tournoi où le soin
coupe pas coupé il peut rien c'est en
fait à wayne ont même fait caméraman il
y peut rien le budget il y peut rien
enfin plein de trucs il en va être pour
moi le format reste mauvais hein
en fait si je devais donner une note les
trucs c'est d'habitude serait un ou deux
sur dix est là on sera quatre sur dix
têtes 3,93 sur dix n'est jamais mieux
mais pour moi ça en vrai en termes de
format pour la paix tout ça n'attend pas
la moyenne devrait devrait enfin y a
qu'à voir la salle 0 public mauvaise
régie du coup difficile faudrait plus de
budget quand même sur les cas mon
pourrait faire quelque chose de mieux ça
sera important puis le format est quand
même relativement mauvais on va pas non
plus se mentir c'est sympa parce que
c'est un format coupe mais ça dure trois
semaines
au bout d'un moment cette heure fut
longtemps que les gigots quoi quelques
petites erreurs tout le temps et c'est
bien de temps en temps peut-être un peu
oubliée alors pas oublié parce qu'on a
fait le ton à mx donc on a suivi le
tournoi qui inclut les hommes et les
femmes non mais c'est important de le
souligner ce que je vois j'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois la fuite pour leur dire
si on suit le tournoi qui inclut les
femmes
donc il ya les hommes les familles à
tout le monde après le ton à kiki qui
exclut donc avec par un niveau inférieur
bon c'est vrai qu'on l'a pas suivi mais
comme j'aurais pas suivi un championnat
junior qui exclurait les adultes mme
adjani a affirmé zhao quoi baffie round
jackie est jeune ou sinndar of the story
of on les a suivis
chez les mx fin dans toutes catégories
d'appareils qui aurait eu une catégorie
junior avec ses parents il y aurait pu
avoir qui ont vu ni connu
sarah nord oues arana où je sais pas on
n'aurait pas suivi non plus en vrai donc
là on a fait pareil en soi d'ailleurs eu
marquant
non on n'aurait pas dessus on arrive
demain mais c'est comme tant qu'anti à
roland garros juniors en général non il
ya personne qui regarde le gardien mais
tu vois un petit encadré l'équipe à la
fin à machin a gagné n'a pas les matches
mais c'est pareil mais disons que et la
clôture in non elle a été sortie il y
aura un toit ou tram et un tournoi
femmes j'aurais peut-être fait
différemment très honnêtement j'aurais
peut-être un peu plus sur la caméra qui
vous ont créé le sens c'est pas dommage
que je change un film bien sûr même
temps que championnat mixte ça empêche
les femmes de participer au championnat
mixte alors ça c'est tout à fait vrai
rapide without stream
après peut-être un jour décidé d'appeler
ça mepha bruce ivins mais l'appellation
te laisse à penser que pas pourquoi pas
voir une gare yatch qui n'assure leeuwen
mixte enfin quand je vois un style d'art
of qui arrive au 4e tour des garages qui
n'a aurait pu y arriver joue elle je
n'aurais pu le faire après c'est aussi
la décision des femmes de ne pas jouer
l'événement enfin annoncé leur décision
mais tout s'est passé pas c'est pas la
nôtre en fait
c'est pour rassurer la règle est parue
dans le temps et féminin mais enfin tu
en as mixant femmes cependant d'être un
tournoi il faut arrêter la mauvaise foi
alors c'est pas de la mauvaise foi c'est
les femmes ont refusé de le jouer en a
qui ont été invitées elles ont refusé
après nous on peut rien de faim nous
quand on commente on peut rien y faire
en fait qu'elle refuse de jouer non mais
je leur gouvernement ont dit oui mais ya
pas de fabas ouais mais enfin si tu dis
non non non non non enfin là ok tu veux
y en a pas mais c'est pas la faute ni de
nous ni des organisateurs ou quoi ça on
n'y peut rien après bonsoir moi je
serais pour que les deux compétitions
soient pas en même temps effectivement
et qui ait plus de femmes qui viennent
participer à cet événement la quitte à
donner des wild cards non mais tu fais
des qualifs escalé fille qui se qualifie
comme il y avait une case qualifié à la
championne du monde a le droit d'être là
elle aurait pu être la vraie fille dans
les championnats d'europe ou quoi qui
sont mixtes et des places à prendre
quand même et à des places à prendre mon
mal d'ailleurs guère yatch finale s'est
qualifié pour la finale russie
karachi a tout intérêt à participer au
tournoi féminin si elle doit choisir
entre les deux alors qu'elles peuvent
parfaitement faire les deux après polgar
depuis tout petit j'ai déjà dit à son
père il était absolument contre qu'elle
fasse les compétitions féminines à la
fédé mixte elle a terminé 8e mondial et
donc après est-ce que c'est pas
finalement un choix au rabais que décidé
de ne pas le choix on doit dire tu as
belfort où tu as le choix tu veux un tel
choix de tout tout le temps en fait me
demander des concessions des machins de
suivre un rêve de faire des efforts mais
le droit de dire non à tout et n'importe
quoi donc voilà je n'aime pas trop être
critique qui dit ça parce que je la
trouve injustifiée si tu veux les femmes
peuvent se qualifier aux candidats à
bâtir une femme qui finissait qui allait
en finale de la coupe du monde elle peut
aller fouiller les candidats ou plus le
feu les candidats de payer matches de
magnus est champion du monde c'est plus
interdit quoi ces êtres humains contre
être humain quoi au final
l'argent est trop important pour être
qu'elles ont le choix nous dit c'est ton
avis c'est ton point de vue suis battu
connaît pas leur compte en banque passe
qu'elle gagne ce qu'elles font à ce que
je voyais ne joue pas du tout pour la
peine elle n'est pas venue jouer la
compétition non plus en fait non
oui fans dont fouet et puis tu as des
jeux ce qui était déjà qualifiée pour le
tour des candidats au féminin ouais donc
voilà c'est juste un une critique qui
est un petit peu un petit peu un petit
peu injuste je trouve là dessus hop ou
preuve trois ans puis on sait si ce
peuple a en plein d'autos ouais là ça va
faire une petit turbo droart mon fab bas
il va essayer peut-être de moi je peux
le faire mais c'est de faire b4 un jour
quoi ouvrir un peu attaqué un peu
bessette
mais c'est très solide évidemment
shekhar yakine donc y aller noir autour
au centre je crois temps d un semblant
chants claque qui voit sa fin arriver un
gros nom née pour chanter là après 1 on
sera très heureux pour lui après moi je
pense qu'avec qui me sur gros favoris
mais bon maxime qui vient juste pour les
caméras au vol du cadrage très
qualitatif 1 à zoug au plat et j'adore
quoi ça me fait penser je rappelle au
sketch des inconnus et où j'ai envie de
gerber il en veut plus alléchants clan
n'a bonga bonga sachant que la france a
fait deux saisons que la paire montre
qu'un mec
pour jean [ __ ] oui on y fait des
choses que je disais la fin vous serez
vous qu'ils fassent des gros watts pour
un parti j'aurais été nul
le prince dégage
lui qui me ramène avec grande qualité qu
afin peut-être un streamer venue d'un
autre continent pour fait camaret non
c'est pas enfin c'est possible je pense
un streamer américain qui donne je ne
sais pas elles sont bien ces photos ou
pas rose anne d'ailleurs va demander je
me suis peut être mal exprimé il ne fait
pas il ne faut pas faire de polir de
unis fans ce que sont des exceptions
malheureusement c'est la fidh avait une
réelle volonté de changer les choses je
pense ça parce que déjà par la mixité
dans les compétitions jeunes or ce n'est
pas le cas mais je suis assez d'accord
avec votre chaise 525 après je suis pas
sûr d'avoir raison
c'est ma conviction aussi à mes faut
faire preuve et je suis pas sûr d'avoir
été juste faut faire et puis on verra
dans 20 ans et si ça marche pas bon se
posera votre question mais tant que tu
fais pas ton sérieux façon d'agir pour
le gouvernement décide de rien en fait
on n'est dans aucune instance de riom
monde jamais notre avis de rien on
commande on fait nos trucs en bon ordre
à un avis quoi mais il sera jamais rien
va jamais de fait et ça n'a jamais
changé de ce côté là parce que les
photographes sont bien payés alors tu
peux trouver cette info damien d publié
à l'époque rage espère ne pas dire de
bêtises mais sur les candidats qui tue
le match championne du monde qui a duré
trois semaines
ouais en russie donc celui de sotchi
c'était lequel de gueule fondamente non
celui le carlton annoncé qu'un texte et
kahlan et le premier alors donnant le
12e 2014 2014 2014 je crois que c'était
4 4500 $ + tous frais payés
c'est pas mal trois semaines de mémoire
d'amar donc là je sais pas si les tarifs
ont été revus mais c'est une information
que vous pouvez éventuellement trouver
d'autres les frais étaient bien dans ton
avion de ton hôtel tuer des listes est
bien triste night club tu prends tes
4005 donc si tu viens des états unis
spécialement pour prendre des photos en
officiel ça peut ça peut atteindre un
billet quasiment dix mille tout compris
ouais bon après c'est normal aussi qu'on
paye le voyage a honnêtement
surtout que ça dure enfin un registre
très difficile donc c'est normal
d'appeler une compétence surtout en
période de quatre ans j'avais wimbée g
normal parfois sur youtube et idy
l'aviez pas le bon alors attends merci
de l'info c'est censé être le bon mais
il arrive qu'il ya un bug donc c'est
cool
d'habitude je vérifie enfin ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas fait jusqu'à ça
ça marchait bien régner un bug
effectivement du coup merci à toi sap a
pris le changement de twitch des fois
drs et un autre truc qui a fait le buzz
mais je vais le corriger immédiatement
c'est un bug qui arrive quand tu stream
sur les deux plateformes en même temps
vers ces bonbons régler vrai j'ai
combiné la coupe du monde tous les deux
ans et les deux ans mais en fait c'est
un tournoi qualificatif aux candidats
donc ça suit le rythme des candidats
c'est ça l'était avant les candidats qui
sont toujours au printemps jeune homme
faris et neuf mois avant les candidats
généralement ils ont été volés piednoël
il a deux jours de repos il est très
heureux quoi parce que demain
djouba de marsanne joue par m tu me fais
honte qu'on tient à ce sujet ce coup
même si à plus de français ben écoute je
vais demander à chess comme normalement
j'étais censé suivre jusqu'aux demi
finales je leur demandais si l on
continue ou pas on verra bien on verra
bien si s'il le souhaite pas je pense
pas en fait
enfin un petit résumé youtube mais voilà
c'est ça ouais ouais je gagnais en
époque personne ne verra ni moins
longtemps et ouais c'est vrai mais le
truc c'est qu'en fait c'est décalé c'est
comme par le champion olympique la 2 qui
aura à tokyo du 100 m il sera champion
olympique que trois ans comme sera
pareil 2024 et basses que yugo vides et
qu'il ya peut être championne l'an
dernier donc ça va être le cas dans
plein de compétition et dont les échecs
donc fait le choix du monde aurait dû
avoir lieu en 2020 by ap amy a pas eu et
le problème c'est qu'ils avaient pas de
changer en fait que les rentes et les
candidats au mieux mais ils ont quand
même sauvé le cycle bon là c'est mans
series à la vue de tous les sports
beaucoup de mal à réunir dans la même
pièce
oui enfin d'affaires des maisons en de
tennis on va faire des trucs mais là
c'était ce que c'était c'était compliqué
c'est comme ça et est donc voilà donc il
règnera moins longtemps effectivement
c'est la conférence web wallon les
compris fille d'avoir bien sûr mais bon
déjà farsi qualifier ça passe déjà par
les signes que fit cap un fab en août
qui sera très importante pour lui et le
web fait tout est toujours important en
fait voilà
c'est vrai que d'habitude souhaitant un
privé on y accorde moins d'importance en
soi ça te qualifies pour rien alors
c'est toujours cool d'ajouter une ligne
à son palmarès
et c est après ça avec nos échecs dans
le titre suprême ses champions du monde
et donc tous les tournois qui peuvent
mener au graal mais vu que pour aller au
grand prix fidh qui seront qualificatifs
sera important d'avoir un bon lots du
coup chaque tournoi va compter et va
être important donc signe que fildak
font évidemment là il hoffman à fond
parce que ça peut donner un ticket à 6
si on termine dans les deux premiers et
puis toute façon faire un bon tournoi
c'est toujours bien ça rapporte des
points elo et avoir donc un bon
classement au 1er décembre donc
important voilà
et après ben après bah oui enfin maxime
façon ben gers il joue bien il joue bien
et on va se qualifier ses valises ou mal
à la tête mais souvent c'est comme ça en
fait mais là il est l'herbe retrouver
une bonne bonne petite forme c'est
normalement c'est en la qualification
comme ça knock out
il est plutôt bien à l'aise il a quand
même fait déjà trois fois demi finaliste
de cette coupe du monde je ne sais pas
c'est pas anodin de répéter d'avoine
régularité et donc voilà il y pas
faciles à battre après un rapide il est
très bien ambitieux très bien donc
donc bien sûr il peut le faire après
tout on peut pas te certifier enfin on
est sur un gros quart yakine fait pas on
n'est pas devin mais allait tomber sur
un gros carré king tu peux toujours
tombé sur un mec sort un gros match ces
ballons signoret copains ou une grosse
partie où tu fais gaffe à un moment même
si justement dans les faits il fait pas
quoi mais mais tu sais pas mais sur du
gros se prépare au machin appuie les
grands prix fille deux suivants qui joue
ça peut être fort c'est à dire que si tu
as les qui décide de jouer on sait pas
pourquoi
que ta caruana qui est encore là il va
pouvoir le sortir des pointes à rogner
un peu sur green shoots à ding ding
bien sûr il n'y a que deux places enfin
rien que enfin parlant de finir derrière
dean gayssot c'est pas une honte à mes
rayons de sa queue en fait tu peux très
bien jouer maxime max et put adding max
somac sghir imax caruana max et tu te
fais troisième ou quoi et ça peut rien
même nation ajar là au bout d'un moment
c'est
et il risque d'y avoir beaucoup de très
gros joueurs pour deux places pour deux
places en fait faut en fait faut bien
jouer il faut la petite réussite mois
non c'est souvent ça dans plein de
sports et est donc voilà les pas de la
partie en cours bas si on en a déjà
parlé ici rien se passer ça va faire du
bien ouais bon bah si tu veux un petit
détail c'était une catalane l'ouverture
là on a une position il reste deux tours
une dame qui avait lifou de clo reposer
et se passe pas grand chose dans ce cas
pas de faiblesse ni d'un côté et de
l'autre donc avec les blancs il va peut
être essayer de percer un moment faire
b4 on voit pas trop comment parce que
fawcett pion à 5 sa contrôle bien essayé
de percer au centre par ou 4 à voir mais
sais tu laisses des quatre fragile donc
le plus vraisemblable c'est que ça va
être un statu quo même si les blancs
peuvent essayer des manoeuvres va se
qualifent 4k et détroit pour venir en c5
ou je ne sais où mais ça peut ça peut
tourner longtemps
objectivement objectivement ça se passe
pas grand chose donc à voir si se passe
un truc et là on le dira mais l'a pour
l'instant c'est du jeu de manoeuvre va
du roi g23 g7
mes parents de la manoeuvre que si tu
bouges un peu ce feu le chauffeur
l'épilation tu cliques au hasard est
vraiment m'aider c'est qu'ils soient pas
trop hasardeux bien cliqué pour le coup
et au hasard quand même
ouais voilà après avoir si quelqu'un va
prendre un risque concret qui ne le
voient pas prendre un risque
lui il est content si ça fait nul après
l'oral et blanc et shankland va écouter
une pollution il a pas de risque il
chauffe 'le les pièces et puis et puis
voilà si nul nul mais une autre partie
est à son psy père celle là il sait que
c'est dînatoire donc il peut pas se
suicider non plus là il fait dame 700
élèves du vis-à-vis de la tour c 2 et
attend quoi pourquoi pas fou beckham
oui pourquoi pas je te très bien fou
mais quatre aussi ses choix qui apparaît
en mauvais coup pour le mans as tu veux
jouer à peu près n'importe quoi tu dois
juste attendre un temps tu touches pas
tu es pions tu fume pas une pièce
emprise sur calais ou quatre ça va faire
flouer quatre peut-être pour ces deux
fruits disney ce but revient
un petit conseil pour les gens du ce
genre de position avec les noirs comme
ça m'arrive assez souvent c'est de rien
faire la forêt faire donc c'est de n'en
rien faire du tout mais vraiment rien
faire genre réellement des cadres est ce
qu'il a fait est là en vrai fou d ici
c'est un coup par exemple du 6 5 ou deux
tours d'une case devant tours 17 tours 7
j'aurais peut-être les tours c'est cette
histoire dès cette date il va retourner
avec dams et 7 on sait pas pourquoi
bref plein de coups francs faut attendre
après faire un coup comme ces cinq ça
peut se regarder évidemment sans
exception le plan b c'est tu me tremblay
six trous sur noir mais bon pourquoi
faire en fait enfin je ne rien faire ça
suffit pas et c5 c6 tu penses que tu
fais nul en force
voilà il a bougé un coup de tour du
mondial ouais j'ai tu estimes tu sais ça
c'est à kenner tu bouges trop tu peux te
faire des faiblesses et vice versa avec
les blancs en fait est-ce que quatre
cinquièmes va pas forcément faite aux
4/5 je suis pas sûr que tu accomplis ce
grand chose de ce tout à fait mis la
casse des cinq donc le cavalier
viendrait se planter au mieux ici qu'à
ceux des 5
et puis torres au pied arrière et donc
le prix de méteren tour
et c est très pesant plus de mobilité
avec des pièces après c'est peut-être
jouable assure serait d'ailleurs mais je
suis pas convaincu que ça te donne masse
de choses avec le vent mais bien à
l'époque c'est quand il faisait 4 5 et
des cinq dates des 8,5
en fait nous puissons sur le dos après
s'il veut faire un truc shankland
peut-être il va tenter ça n'a pas l'air
réfuté non plus un pour les mains mais
c'est à double tranchant est vraiment
double tranchant en fait c'est plus lui
avec le rail concorde marge au carnet
qui ne savait difficile 1 pour maxime de
rester leader bah ouais parce que l'an
plus avec des rondes en moins et qui
gagnera le match pour la troisième place
marquer des points bonus toi tu
remplaces l'épave a le double c'est vrai
que bakir a très peu marcher un domaine
rapport à ce qu'il aurait pu faire
il a été
concentré sur le chic il ya un petit peu
déçu sur sur ce concours de marche on
aurait pu attendre d'un joueur qui
arrive en quarts de finale qu'ils
marchent à fond tu marches un peu plus
l'écart yakine cela fait une énorme
performance contre maxime je veux
refaire avec sa part les doigts c'est
vrai qu'il a fait très très mal à la
carafe à maxim lamarche à fond avant la
whey à bas toute façon c'est toujours un
peu les mêmes qui sont en tête guy
maxime car yakine des marcheurs ouais on
a quand même des grands des grands
leaders baky qui aurait pu se révéler
dans ce tournoi mais a eu 4 4 il valait
tant il tente mais il a peut-être enfin
on verra bien le temps du match mais je
veux dire vrai que je joue avec les
nerfs il souffrir avec les noirs c'est
dommage
après là je veux dire qu'il a rien fait
avec les blancs mais jusqu'à qu'il lui a
égalisé la tête et voilà qui fut double
tour sur des tapas trop impressionné le
4s est pas impressionnant vrai non non
non mais c'est bien de prendre de
l'espace un nom l'andra au cap des 4
c'est un conseil condamne tout le temps
donc je ne peux pas être trop mal mais
là bon comme qui avait bien il a déjà
changé deux pièces le fougueusement chez
un cavalier et donc d'être dans cet
espace réduit avec deux pièces échangées
normalement on s'en tire bien hier
chaque pièce à sa case le fourbe et 4
bat il est pas mal le khalife suisse il
est là si tu fais attaquer il sera bien
en dessin que les tours sont doublés
donc en fait on a juste suffisamment
d'espacé par les pièces dégueulasse ce
avec landrin foncé 8 en plus on dire ah
bah voilà ça c'est un problème assez
piquerez la s'appliquerait mais là non
on ajuste les bonnes pièces et enlevez
moi je suis souvent content qu'il fonde
4 parce qu'avant à
ce qui se passe c'est que qq1 trois
excellentes a vraiment pas de plan est
en fait constituée de quatre au moins tu
as été là et tu commences avoir des
idées tu dit ya peut-être des attaques
et des 80 pour l'instant il est bien
tenu mais voilà qu'elle y part déjà les
plus que les tours qui défendra déjà tu
peux penser à venir
voilà par exemple et tout est changé en
force et faire juste d'euros voilà où
peut-être jouer des majorités contre une
autre mais 5 oui ça m'a l'air assez
logique après peut-être tu fais rien
savent aussi mais bon on veut trouver le
coup rien faire ou simone le 5 sud
accueille oui ça sent toujours plus ça
que moi donc tu es dans le réflexe hm55
coup je regarde a aussi sévi hier quand
je suis passé voir ton cours je vous
écoute dernièrement commun qui fut
reprend dessine call cac et prend des
signes coup est parti tout de suite
t'as pas montrer mon piège préféré à wim
sections ont préféré je montre un piège
on sait entre nous avec fabre
t'as pas rentrer le piéjos mais moi je
veux pas faire sauf 5ème sur celui-là
sur celui-là racing coq et c3 aussi 6h
4.493 foulée six dames b3 je suis très
heureux d'un coup agité que un piège ces
dames v6 que souvent les mecs en face
font fusé de part et flex que le poussin
ces deux temps forts l'autre ou alors
ils te font c'est ça que tu bouffes
aussi dans l'appareil g5 il pas encore
rodé maintenant on s'en fout les trois
mois de l'été j'étais très déçu tu
rentres pas ce genre le cours de fac
j'attends et le piéjos avec grande
armada du tueur fou 4 je supprime étape
a montré le chef non mais je pense quand
même les blancs et va lui prendre son
sujet si c'est pas laisser l'autre
hanche cap et à dire que je les place et
hikaru à ce mot j'adore ce film et
parents de faire d'un v6 très vite
quasiment prêt vous j'en retiens tout
est normal
on le te fais foulée de vérification
d'amérique à rouler réagi les dégoûter
de feytiat trouvé matthieu excès mais
j'étais pas en forme mais par contre
j'avais fait nul contre le nord le petit
gambie ce cas au kenya des ressources qu
avec les blancs si tu joues bien mais le
petit camp du coup ils agissent du gange
et on a fait nul mais je serais heureux
de se fier
je suis très déçu quand ils passent pas
par contre du coup c'est certain mais il
a évité que les chalets placé abivie ça
aussi non mais ils passent beaucoup en
fait non c'est vrai que tu dois venir
bah il est trés jeff quoi bon là ça va
faire nul en liga ya vraiment ces mêmes
les blancs là qu'il va faire peut-être
bon mais il va faire choco dam des 27
qui fait 2007 tu vas me rispat adam
c'est quoi
si tu l'as moshi fille marie spaeth adan
fait dams est en fait je pensais dam des
quêtes qui prend bekkat d'un premier 4t
change tout eu rendre payant dès cet été
peut-être bien mais ça ne me riess pas
pris sur balles perdues à merise est une
pièce ça fait très longtemps qu'on le
dit je ne sais pas c'est pas comme si
c'était une nouvelle expression voix
clarence york en mai mais les durs
karékine ii battre une fois c'est quand
même ses gonds partie d'entre eux c'est
beau champion mais en fait je sais pas
le le point de vue car yakine mais je le
sens sur deux doit gagner quand je suis
comme ça mais quand même ceci fait le
coup avec les blancs à trop faire seul
studio qui il a déjà un peu forcé je
suis à deux doigts et à la majorette ll
damme 6e
en fait je suis très heureux tu vas sur
ça je lui ai eu quatre avec les noirs
pour moi souvent soulagement jeudi a
enfin j'ai un plan c'est qu'avant c'est
vrai que si tu commences à tacty vêtu si
tu faisais un ces cinq points ou 1,5 à
ventes affaiblies s'était case quoi
c'est qu'il a fait quatre ans fait son
curieux cathy blocs sont fous s'ils
commencent à pousser duo signe qu on
peut repartir même verger 4 vers des 5es
hockey à vrai dire ce genre de cas de
figure c'est bien moi je suis content en
fait on va échanger les tours et puis
bon ben on va jouer coiffage et caïques
oncle fouge la majorité à elle dame
nantes et ses pions sont fixés d'autres
côté de ces scissions adam des trois
prises j'échange affiné avec le cavalier
les belles natures
il bosse au petit hall est très bien car
je marche
ouais bah il est entraîné par diniz un
appareil qui le seconde a annoncé dans
ses efforts de marche
il n'a pas pu s'aligner sur les jeux
olympiques à cette année comme ça
coïncide atteint sidéré si on l'aurait
vu du côté de tokyo
peut-être parler de 1024 il très chaud à
bâiller très bien regarde à une belle
démarche un champion qui suit à ce
niveau là il n'a pas été retenu mais
même en rapide ans tu vois mais même en
blitz
je pense qu'il parle de partir marcher
quelques heures après un coup d'avancé
que tôt m ouais c'est toujours ça de
pris
c'est le cameraman qui reste vraiment
sûr shankland à olemps
si un tremblement de terre sotchi 5,5
peut-être bien joué ou cinq pays qui
avait beaucoup progressé shankland ce
qui fait les positions de la garde très
importantes les distinguent ou kg 4
cette façon il a bien dit un s'empalant
n'y a que le travail comme c'est beau
c'est ce qu'il dit de lui-même un verre
par les coulées mais j'aime bien les
gens conscients de leur niveau
et puis bah qui font les efforts
pourquoi il fait pas le malin ils en ont
ils travaillé tout à mes très concentré
ce bois foncé façon très honorable quoi
comme démarche mais c'est bon je trouve
je pense à donner espoir à beaucoup de
gens tu as qui se demandent ce que je
croyais aux échecs ou quoi on peut
arriver sans talent réel à 2007
j'en suis convaincu et moi je suis en
jeu quelques idées en tête
quelques exemples en tête arrive c'était
pas possible avant en fait non avant
c'était plus difficile non mais juste
impossible là avec les ordis et que les
bases de données avec tout ça et les
ordis juste qu'ils vont faire les
analyses pour toi tu retiens tout sûrs
place le truc on 10h ans
là quand même du talent ces deux c'est
lui qui le dit hein les dessins écrit
carioca s'est vite médicale à baltard
pour être ta vie ça moi je les dis que
il est moi j'ai lu qu'ils avaient dit
qu'ils avaient pas de talent bah je sais
pas j'ai pas vu c'est sur son twitter
bonsoir à tous et changé dans le monde
il a fait qu'aider 5 et non mais là
sûrement un talent pour beaucoup
travaillé on c'est une forme de talent
aussi mais je veux dire par là il n'a
pas de talent spécifique aux échecs
n'ont été que le sens dans ce sens là
après il doit être très intelligent et
calcul est vite mais il doit pas avoir
un talent naturel pour il a un très joli
nom aussi 20 ouest france perche en khl
il fit parkland ouais donc la tête
remettre à jour je vais l'utiliser 5e
bien parti mais je sais pas complexe ça
que ça c'est quelque chose les gens s'en
sont plaints que consortium jeu de
remettre à jour et qu'on n'est pas les
coups mais bon sang des ivoiriens on n'y
peut rien or à chaque fois et a stressé
je sais pas comme il joue ses coûts vite
là il est pas très bon rapide qu'à venir
et vlad comme beaucoup de joueurs est
mauvais en rapide ils ont l'impression
qu'ils doivent jouer vite mais je sais
pas s'il doit jouer vite ses coûts mais
en fait la manière bougies ces pièces
étaient très nerveuses il a l'air
nerveux mais ils bougent pas ses pièces
comme kaixin quoi il bouge il bouge pas
ouais bon positionnement regarde après
faut la jouer un jeu ça peut se perdre
ça peut se gagner ces trucs à mais c'est
pas mal joué dams et 2 je pense qu'il va
essayer si la dame se barre de prendre
des matelas d'avancé 5
non mais au moins il fait une partie il
fait peu nul direct essayez-le c'est
yann même nom mais après tu vois c'est
peut-être son hôte ont travaillé ils
auraient été 25 50 26 quoi il a fait le
jem par 27 des quelque gagné
championnats des états unis
c'est incroyable on expliquera m c'est
en fait en face tanaka caruana et ce au
juste les autres qui sont paille ou les
robson l'egypte a qui n'en est peut-être
sans être une brute de travail comme ça
ils bloquent à 26 quoi mais entre 26 et
27 la différence elle est tellement
énorme
- ou peut-être même moins je sais pas en
fait fin du radio non mais je sais
qu'ils y travaillent beaucoup de bien
sûr il est toujours prêt machine
non c'est beau pas de limite d'âge pour
commencer par des tournées ben non en
vrai ce tournant ils sont vraiment
ouvert à tout ça je crois que ça fait
caillasser 7
ouais je veux beaucoup d'euros pièce sur
la septième rangée en vie puisque les
américains sur trec tomeing h à la
médaille mondiale du cdpa enfin c'est
quand même oui mais je sais pas je me
trop compris entre faut quand même se le
farcir 1,1 me suis pas pressé de le
battre mais c'est clairement moins fort
que les trois autres et je sais pas j'ai
pas si c'est plus fort 2010 est ce que
chante landou c'est pas mieux un petit
âge des fonctions coup dur à dire en
fait un petit chien blanc bilan ou non
mais 2015 en fait ça va c'est vrai qu'il
est de 1750 et forcément il est arrivé
là par hasard mais je sais pas en fait
ce que je sais même pas comment ils
avaient là je vois jamais gagné un seul
tournoi où il joue jamais en fait
lagache championnat du monde de bridge e
sa caméra
d'ailleurs on regarder le palmarès 10k
rouillard c'est qu'il a un palmarès
comme assez impressionnant ouais enfin
bon ça qui fait gagner gagner fish and
this pas mal légaliser olympiades
gagnante chez ce tour en fin de l'année
jeanne et huawei l'année ce total c'est
pas mal mais après bon après c'est vrai
que ça comptait pas les tentations
internet dans le palmarès c'est un truc
long comme le bras
mais je voyais cas moins beau palmarès
hikaru il a aussi gagné zurich plusieurs
mois participer aux candidats quand même
malgré tout c'est quand même
mais monsieur il reprendra pour 200 m
dos est peut-être une petite mc5 mais
est ce qu'il n'aurait pas obtenu quelque
chose shankland là le tarn en tête
peut-être proche ce serait beau quand
même que ça mayer en demies la charte
qui met en mode contre attaque massés en
ville d'hama cette dame v2 dame bessette
qui avait lieu 6 à 5
c'est la course 1 ouais d'accord ça a
l'air bien pour les blancs quoi manger
quand une course et que tu as un foot
est content quand même y aura des
karellis et sinko des québécois trop
d'écueils sait si coca et détresse mais
bon karekin qui a été un peu car vache
est en fait sa séquence acquiescé c'est
tout quoi ça jusqu'à présent sous les 32
premiers coûté très bien il va rien à
dire ils regardent ce soit qui sait
qu'il vient regarde et très sexy tu es
regarde comme un guépard un peu près 10
e il veut bondir les amis lb alors frôlé
la chante la rga ayez trésor grecs
accusaient oui il est vraiment très con
en face où la dame des six ok peut-être
je sais pas mais sa force faisant les
changements on accueille des cinq aussi
regarder les eaux il est heureux regarde
ce qu'il se verrait bien sur la zone cet
échange il veut te faire du foot
français si ce n'est la violence est
magnifique on peut montrer qu'elle
guérisse sam
il a calculé réussisse il va te faire
[ __ ] en c6 bouffer as et à sainte
ouine même schéma on fait beaucoup
d'exercices avec jacko paillardes tu
sais pas eu d'abus d'autorité qui est
des cinq ans qui leur chat sing sing
très intéressant exercice toutes les
semaines je t'envoie le calcul a mis la
précarité il va se le prendre il va
bondir là il avait recensé 13 ans lâche
encore aller monsav à l'essonne non mais
pas du tout il il bondit à fond la
serbie j'ai vraiment beaucoup travaillé
chez quoi être nul chez ex vice champion
du monde je vais te défoncer regarde je
ne fais pas dire si la garde sur la
pendule calculer on commettrait film
mais oui au regard il est heureux il
heureux de vous il a envoyé les gars
désolé pour les français si il va lui
faire un petit ring
shank la regardent ils la font quoi
parents puis 6
archi beau gosse avec sa petite barbe
bien taillée
il n'est pas venu que pour jouer des
échecs à sotchi c'est fabien excuses de
te le dire excuse de te le dire rien tu
regardes il le figra les yeux regarde
ouais je sais que tu calcules et bien
j'ai été souvent rapide et affable et si
c'était ça le rosier tu prends tu fais
le malin que ça va être ta victoire
d'hier regarde gt line et fait le break
sur attaque deux matches nuls en fait ça
m'a rendu tellement heureux la regarde
on regarde le bozoum magnifique le zoom
en mai après niveau du nez savait qu'il
allait il pourra voir le calibre au
dessus quoi je me présente un peu
jusqu'à lui quel niveau n'est pas là
quand même
il va falloir progresser côté chanteurs
ne serait pas sur la chirurgie est
saisie de données vont le faire grossir
et on n'est vraiment pas assez gros
seins sont aussi ceux jusqu'alors rabote
peut même se relever serez vous au non
au contraire à mon bien pointu vient
moitié ok c b6 est alors faut juste pas
faire bref trois motifs ou des 500
hommes pourquoi disent qu'il est
beaucoup trop fils ben je sauve alors il
est où ton toujours bouche du magnifique
halle berry fait un petit sourire
intérieur regarde regarde et celle sur
soi un petit sourire intérieur alors
qu'ils calculent ils cachent rien dit et
coup chef des femmes sont mortes sous
tac tac tox l ami noël filant des 5000
et beaumont chanteloup 1
mais je m'attendais pas du tout en fait
j'étais un peu en sueur dans mon île va
se défoncer en fait non en effet le cfa
est en sueur silva shankland en face
franquiste
surya qui n'est bon du coup à bout d'un
an tu te dis vous choque là est vraiment
un bond de 6,2 tout cas c'est beaucoup
c'est à fait les exercices du killer
chez steam sting qu'ils ont leur
classement sur ce que tu as trouvé
peut-être en fait parce qu'un gars dit
je suis pas du tout surpris enfin pu
sans résultat tout à fait normal qu'il
ait défonce en fait être qui voit les
résultats et dit oui mais en fait tu es
plus fin
non c'est très fort comme tu dis que tu
as pas talent m'étais beaucoup plus fort
que ces idiots qui a du talent que ce
serait beau et à vrai dire shankland en
fait c'est super talentueux le plus
talentueux tous âges en plus qui tombe
très mal pour les noirs je veux dire
c'est ception la fin mais bon ça c'était
l'idée des blancs d'oeufs puis des mains
mais je dirais pas mal c'est juste des
fois quand on demande à un film comme ça
tu veux dire je peux tenir mais là t'as
jamais le roi qui va venir faire ça
parce que bah tu te fais collecter quoi
y'a que ça pour être bas qui mèneront ce
cas le russe s'était pas qui j'ai fondé
singh bafoue ses six bailly ans vient en
fait tu vas faire pousser 6,17 car il
est aussi tu vas te faire beau cadeau a
même poussé 6 3 et 8 17 recettes après
vous et bien là il est pourquoi après
c'est dommage
tu vois on parlait de magnus qui
avantage les avantages et des joueurs
genre duda il est tellement avantage et
je manie son demi davantage en fait
hyper et en tire rejoue pour la cirrhose
ou match courtois il a un double choc
est pareillement de l'autre côté s'ils
sont éliminés que excellent fait
terrible normalement c
mais magnus avant les demies ouais ou
deux c'est tout en fait
magnus en 2007 c'est très bien déjà pas
mal y'aura f6 je crois mon dormir sur
leurs deux oreilles akin en fait c'est
pas tellement les erreurs passées un
ensemble de coûts du coup qui l'a pas vu
il faut prendre ces six ici peut-être
l'idée c'est que ça c'est pas possible
parce que ce pion va partir tout droit
mais revoilà donc soit il fait rien et
puis bah paf paf paf notre windham celui
ci revient au jeu black je suis très
fort on compte une envoyée au brésil je
suis venu pour deux bouffées très bien
un mail pas possible de défendre ça il a
raté lycée pas qui a été le plus
avantagé mais au final c'est pas qui a
été le joueur le plus désavantagés de
tout le tournoi assez peu car à cet
effet c'est dans mon badge au courant
finale juste froid ce n'est pas leur
truc donc aujourd'hui c'est terrible
choisir c'est encore un coup de cas cros
quoi c'est pas précis mais je veux dire
qu'arras s'investit nas est pas simple à
bâtir hatsoff nos jeunes inc et si piano
lui aussi il a été très désavantagé
parce que du coup ils raclent il rate
les quarts de finale 1 j'ai donc lui
pourra pas être qualifié alé lô donc oui
il est extrêmement désavantage est vrai
c'est vraiment un truc de ouf
donc elle essayait un petit geste inco
dû échanger des pions en vrai c'est
bizarre que souvent les gens quand on en
a parlé sur sur le chat ou quoi ils ont
pensé que c'est une critique envers
carlos est de dire qu'il devait pas
jouer le tour et tous les membres et
c'est vraiment une critique contre le
règlement est pas content magnus oui bah
après il peut de lui même ne pas venir
mais il plaint mignard au fisc mais il
n'est pas interdit de le faire un truc
et a pas un truc qui te dit tu dois être
classe c'est l'esprit de la règle dite
pas le faire mais en fait c'est en vue
de faire tu fais comme une tempête comme
tu veux on joue enfin pourquoi pas
jf c'est tout ça par l hyper logis qui
l'a pas fait ces prix ont fléchi mais je
sais pas trop l'idée de ferraille qui
n'en fait puis non plus hein il veut pas
donner tous ses pions pour d'inception
quand même attention si fâché il va être
obligé de faire l'aller 5-1 peut-être
s'attendre
il le regarde il a ajouté un couplet
pouvait déboucher sur bouffe issue qu'un
oui oui et l'argument acheva de dire en
même temps s'il veut conserver son titre
maxi doit faire des compètes le truc
c'est que il ya invité à des compètes
qui refuse chaque jour tu ça ne me
dérange pas si c'est les mêmes qui
redisent le même truc qui changent
jamais d'avis ou si vous êtes nombreux
lors cet avis il trouve ce n'est pas le
seul tournoi en fait tu avais tous les
grands chefs tour grippe à cazères
encore le droit de lot d'échecs
lorsqu'il est super ce qu'on autorise
c'est un peu son métier voulez pas
comprendre en fait je pense sera
expliqué je pense que les trois cas où
tout le monde est au courant et je
n'écrive pas état de genre de mec qui
viennent dire un truc parce qu'il m'aime
bien un truc qui font pas l'effort de
comprendre n'ont pas la capacité de
comprendre ces batailles abandon match
là et karine sont retrouvés au monstre
in life y attendais pas trop je crois ce
qui était très confiant il est son
concurrent de marche et tout c'est un
groupe quand même farine on est très
heureux mais il a attendu en fait il a
attendu alan normalement il y a que dix
minutes de pause
donc ça c'est la bonne nouvelle fab
la partie alors ça reprend je pense moi
je penserai à 15h du goût vous à 14 49
je pense qu'un conteur qui se lance
immédiatement tu auras dans la salle au
moment où l on a un gros cadres à
changer essayer de choper une gamme si
ça passe ça là généralement ils mettent
le une horloge à une hanche de rick
hansen bug fonds levés sont en couple au
revoir les remèdes pour le monde attend
qu'ils reviennent alors par contre ça
c'est du long pas altan ouais on m'a dit
qu'on va pas devoir attendre mais du
coup franc est connue pour être une
autre gamme setu quoi
je pense pas qu'ils attendent la fin de
cette partie ben non mais t'as une
partie non ils vont passer 6 à 1 k
un e-mail ressentent sur la cour du
général s'ils annulent le face à face
les mois mais c'est parce qu'en fait si
shankland se qualifie circa par duda qui
on aurait pu imaginer au candidat et si
on fait dossier accouchant clan de haut
niveau se battront mais déjà duda c'est
une solitude c'est pas une grande
surprise mais c'est une surprise
ouais ben raide on sait qu'il ya des
tensions sur un match ou quoi m'en vais
pas m'en aller au bout du truc méchant
clan des fêtes au cfc clairement de
l'acabit de alexanian quoi en fait foi
d'ailleurs ils ont le même et locales
excellent colons d'années quand il s'est
qualifié failli lui la wild card jackson
est la plus fort qu'à l'excellent mais
je dirais même que je chante landi
l'offre ouais mais fausse émission vieux
en plus sont entre guillemets avec thank
où il était jeune et tu sais pas
vraiment ce qu'il vaut là on est surpris
par une forte pression mais c'est une
connerie non mais j'ai au moment où il
le foetus est pas par là on est sur des
joueurs on sait qu'ils sont en bon état
hier mais en fait non jamais top 10
mondial
non non non à l'excellent coach aurait
pu avoir le doute au moment où il s'est
qualifié ma vie tu fais pas trop mais
géré que là tu es quand même faire un
champ cloud c'est vraiment un joueur
dans la phase descendante normalement
shankland en fait je suis hyper sûr il
serait tombé en vrille et plus après
s'inquiète un tel qu vide qui fait qu'il
n'ya plus rien mais déjà j'ai intense
dans un moment qu'on vit quasiment plus
votre temps je sais même pas si les
chemins des états unis fin quand ça fait
un foyer dans l'anonymat total il a
peut-être fait 6e non mais je me dis bon
bois juste s'en fout il faut autre chose
de sa vie quoi c'est cournoyer puis bâle
a en fait l'histoire son tournoi
bon après j'ai pas encore
et un guerrier qui ne va pas lui rendre
la vie facile mais en fait je
m'attendais pas du tout à ça c'est à
vrai dire fab sea doo dah s'allumer un
coup de fouet à caen j'ai un goût tout
une amie au figuratif un jeu pas l'air
si les gens commencent à le souhaiter
ça c'est une goutte voilà il faut
préciser mais je préfère me saluer un
coup de fouet donc au sens figuratif du
terme et que ça le motive pour
travailler pour se préparer en fait
d'être qualifié un peu interdit celui
clairement doublon c'est en fait c'est
un genre de maxime n'est pas choisie au
sol mais en fait il y fort il un
répertoire un peu de merde par rapport
aux autres à ce niveau là alors il
essaie de combler un besoin de la petrov
a des trucs un peu mais c'est qu'il -
moins complet dans l'ouverture et donc
ça peut être une opportunité
ça peut être le truc özil bon bah là je
suis obligé de faire parce que je dois
bosser je vais m'entourer peut-être il
faut avoir une bourse gouvernementale et
caetera et ça peut faire en vrai ça peut
faire la diff abia pas d'autres non mais
je lui souhaite d'ailleurs ben saada -
joueurs à lui pour le coup quand on
parle aux joueurs talentueux je pense
qu'il a le talent et que faudrait se ce
côté là de bien s'entourer
y aller à fond quoi ils pourraient le
faire et ça peut lui donner ce cette
motivation et ce petit déclic pour le
faire donc ça peut à ce titre là ça me
ferait plaisir de voir douze ans après
en tant que troy l'ultime du game
évidemment je suis pour une caille de
feydeau cf et champlan deux sièges
chacun sait quelle magnifique opus alive
et c'est qu'on est pas où nos surprises
faut être non mais tu peux avoir encore
du rwanda enfin pas lui même et tu peux
avoir les candidats têtes l'ip année dit
que 2 claude halfen sur dur en 2011
ce serait quand même beau tu peux avoir
quatre plots candidats sur 8 tu peux
vraiment arriver à 4 po et là le tournoi
est extraordinaire parce que là c'est
n'importe qui peut gagner pour mettre
les plots peuvent se battre entre eux
quand pète les plombs moi je suis un
plot je vous la nul tout le temps les
autres peuvent vouloir forcer un plus
mais a gagné on sait pas trop pourquoi
et comment de sa vie mais aujourd'hui
mon petit nid shankland chant tournant
final
oui qu'on le match contre 400 fait
tellement une boucherie après ou compte
nepos m 6 0 comme ça ça peut être aussi
que le plus ridicule de l'année sega
vient à boy je peux pas ne pas empêcher
de penser un jour devant sa place et la
rentrée compliquée mais sa camarade
japon + ans est candidat un radiateur
pas ou ne suivent pas mais pendant ce
temps des qualifiés a serré que de
prendre personnel et l'eau tu te dis
hein
des trains ont peut-être ajouter cette
ligne une fois quand même le vélo c'est
quand même un truc je prends le mec qui
a le meilleur réseau en décembre le
machin en mars tu dis bon prêtre m dans
les lumières vu le joueur du monde à ce
moment-là qua non mais moi je trouve que
ça rajoute du piment quoi ça va aucun
joueur du top 10 ça c'est dur mais on
sait jamais traille maxime qui se
qualifie quand même un français donc
aujourd'hui fan of this way qui
justement il sera de retour si ce qui me
fit non mais ça dépend si ce qu'avec des
rapides
[ __ ] bailly sera pas tout dit même s'ils
viennent toutes ces parties d'ici la
date en 22 et il te reste deux autres
noms mais il est déjà admis région
automne et chant claviers feydeau cmm
tout à marche en fait c'était pas top 10
et je n'ai pas fait voir tu peux avoir
qui en reste très beau d'avoir genre
enfin torah les deux autres d'avoir zéro
bah tu as quand même un époux personne
qui sera que oui mais j'ai eu au delà de
l'arnacoeur on sait pas pourquoi ce
serait beau dakar est ok n'a qu'à un
streamer shipping co peut-être qu'il
amènera un truc comme ça avoir foule
joueurs portent à 2,10 c'est hyper chaud
mais ce qui me vient tout seul ok mais
si t'as maxime le prez nom et maxime ça
va être dur de remonter top 10 14
ça peut se faire que trois victoires je
ne dis pas que c'est facile justice à
hélices ferrucci rouges assis se
qualifieront déjà maxime le prez les
trois fossés fedoseyev shankland et ils
nous en font un dernier
et si bienne quo et donc ta radjabov et
carole scène house enfants de ghayne
jones qui fait à domicile à l'e3 de sa
vie qui se qualifie quoi wadhams madame
ce dernier dernier run alors pourquoi
carlson ne l'aurait pas cette coupe du
monde qualificative pour les candidats y
rien ne dit qu'il battra n'est pour
demain il se trouve qu'on est qualifié
d'office office lorsqu'on perd le match
champion du monde
n'oubliez pas ça redonne c'est vrai on
fait le finaliste des gens bien du monde
à celui qui va perdre le match donc
soigné pause 45 2 fait il jouera les
candidats il est qualifié si veut dire
non il y annonce m'intéresse pas à vous
met donc voilà donc aucun intérêt faire
sans avoir qualifié c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que né paul lui n'est pas venu
faire tourner et radjabov de même on va
t temps qualifié normalement tu es censé
ne pas le jouer c'est dans l'esprit de
la règle en fait qui veulent se
qualifier et jouer après tes pages sont
pas le truc parce qu'on va nous redire
bon oui mais il faut qu'il joue qu'il
s'entraîne beaucoup plus comme ne joue
jamais ailleurs il peut pas y peuvent
elles faire enfin j'ai en moi et ça fait
la réponse
jawad khalifé comment il a une wild card
s'est pas qualifié mais s'était
qualifiée pour les derniers s'il a
refusé de jouer à priori pour une bonne
raison
et puis bah du coup ils ont dit bon
basique que dans les prochains mois
c'est n'importe quoi complètement enfin
disons la fidh fait une connerie et pour
réparer la connerie il en faut une
nouvelle mais il ya des proverbes ça
marchera jamais faire ce qu'ont vécu au
pas de la justice sociale fait c'est
très con actuelle et fabien buffa on
sait pas quand mais c'est pas annuler de
base c'est que là on n'ait pas trop le
l'occasion alors ça mais ça reprendra sa
reprendra en anglais c'est ça c'est
toujours le remix when right way mais en
france ça je n'aime pas qu'on ainsi des
intrus qui se disent
à
deere shankland il ya 27 20 ils montent
après do d'avoir bien qu'ils fassent de
la merde sur toute la saison faut pas
rentrer dans le top 10 escale ici sinon
ça tue nos plans non mais et qui
instaure il fait pareil marque pas trop
de trucs là il est 15e et il est bien
quoi ça qu'il faut pas qu'il faut trop
bien voilà c'est parti à l'âge d'or
phase iii et donc ses 15 heures maison
rentrée à 40 à 59 en fait ouais et
cheval 6,6 ok je pense qu'on peut
envoyer g quattro segeco à tron en
allant tu penses tu anglais on dit tiens
là nul ou pas mais coûte 10 va essayer
déjà il a changé son petit j'ai fait une
française d'autres fois ils ont une
sixième dont une partie du g6
en fait je pense qu'il avait choisi il
avait décidé en amont de joe la signale
ce que j'aime bien dans ce coin de faire
la chambre c'est qu'il va pas changer de
répertoire après sa victoire avec les
blancs il sait pas l'hymne sicilienne
trop dangereux je veux petit nul ou quoi
il se dit bon bah foot façon je suis
plus fort que lui je vais le défoncer
dont killer chelsea n'sync gérant de
très très bons résultats
c'est d'ailleurs très très très bons
résultats et j'en vois quoi ils sachent
est il encore des choses qualifié bah
écoute qui a fait quatre finalistes donc
déjà il fera les grands prix bon gars
prêts à lui de bien jouer au grand prix
évidemment c'est pas s'éloigner de fait
mais le 3 qui prend des quatre il est
dit dans ce conte du fou de la dal cin
dame prend pour reculer salaires le truc
que je ferai demain peut-être que vous
pensez pas qu'on leur dise ng sinko
stranger ouais enfin après logique une
fois qu'on l'a vu agir si ces prépas tu
peux te rappeler ouais ben zekri qui
réfléchit donc peut-être qu'il va faire
et qui prend dès qu'elle s'est déjà
trompé lâchant que là je sais pas c'est
bizarre
on dit sacha ils se qualifient pour les
candidats ou presque chaque candidat ou
presque depuis des années rebbah oui un
imbécile
c'est un bon joueur quel choc on se fait
20 ans qu'ils ont le stylo un dauphin
s'est perdu en 8e 1 peut-être en
huitième contre 12,2 à voter raison
pendant mai mais bon il sera par le vélo
non allemand ne sera pas loin mais
pardon ça va tu as raison il a perdu un
ultime c'est pour ça que j'ai que pour
maxime ce qui est pas très bien c'est
qu'ils aient beaucoup de joueurs forts
fort d'un autre côté c'est bien pour lui
si car yakine père parce que du coup il
prend une place grand prix ici et y en a
deux autres qui vont prendre des places
candidats pour novembre est une alors
que les autres prendre un plat ce
candidat c'est plutôt l'intérêt de
maxime qui le chante la mine cachant que
la gagne
non on prend tout de cette dame et les
rangs des deux tout comme un joueur
qualifié pour les grands prix c'est 24
je crois qu'ils vont refaire un système
un peu ridicule mais des points de
grands prix mais tu auras pas tous les
mêmes joueurs je crois je ne suis pas
sûr qu'ils repartent à dessus mais je
crois qu'il repart sur les tours en
essais ce qui est complètement contre
l'équité 1 il ya combien de tendre je
crois en toi mais je suis pas sûr non
mais si flou sur sa grille de concèze 16
et 16 h f à temps dans l'es8 juste tu
peux faire avec 24-10 phase de poules ou
tuera des falaises pour tout fait juste
16 et 24 et où quoi en fait c'est quoi
alors délire de faire ce truc côté hong
kong mais ils le font ils ont fait à
chaque fois l'an dernier enfin je sais
mais bon c'est complètement contre
l'équité sportive a une nouvelle fois
qu'il ya des joueurs forts que d'autres
et donc t'as du bol si il ya aussi le
fait que dans un troisième temps à temps
et qui sont déjà éliminés qu'on va rien
à faire rien sur mieux qu'ils font rien
alors que ceux qui vouent les deux
premiers tours à sont clairement à des
favorisés
donc c'est fou de ne pas comprendre ça
en fait un mais ils sont vraiment là où
tu comprends et en a rien à faire et à
d'autres intérêts en jeu mais c'est
grave
non mais moi je pense leur intérêt c'est
de cette faire en sorte que les échecs
soit le moins médiatisé possible souvent
encore bien failli te faisais le truc le
fantastique vous devenu noir une carte à
chaque tournoi
ouais qu'un gars qui me faire l'autre
joker au milieu c'est parce que j'ai à
faire c'est tj hill a aucune chance de
se qualifier de justesse le jkc d'arc
abdul malik qui a gagné le grand prix
féminin
je crois qu'elle était joker en fait et
du coup elle peut pas se qualifier aux
candidats lors qu'elle a la gagne je
veux pas le voir
[Musique]
question bête skis et ski piano par
équipes à la place au grand prix fils de
carl scène non pas du tout après pas il
peut recevoir une wild card mais il peut
parier sur des wild cards de st oui on
ne voit elle car tu vois surtout pauvre
wild card
[Musique]
c'est plus exactement commencé mais j'ai
senti le truc déjà ses complexes à
comprendre
de toute façon il ya une règle à dans le
sport en général c'est de faire des
règles saint cloud simple à comprendre
pour le public est là déjà même en
lisant la règle j'ai pas réussi à la
comprendre du premier coup parce qu'ils
n'aiment pas ce qu'ils veulent dire donc
c'est déjà mauvais si on dirait la
kamoulox même le camelot c'est beaucoup
plus subtil enfin ils vont relier les
gens les prochains candidats on sait pas
on sait pas ni où ni quand d'ailleurs on
se qualifie pour un truc on s'effraie ni
où ni quand mais ce bon sens avoir lieu
en général c'est vers mars avril quoi
l'épreuve en russie ou alors d'en voir
azerbaïdjan webapi arabi sa fin c'est
pas trop quoi doit dubaï
je suis un peu karine blouët issue bas
en avril a raté le g sync ou en fait ça
devait être dans son fichier que qu'elle
prend des cats étaient mauvais pour g5
26-20 ce graphiste sa turbine vérifier
mais c'est possible et c'est possible
juste qu'il soit par rapport à pelé du
fichier 1
et georges et oui il a raison la plupart
du temps là la règle des wild cards
c'est parce qu'une personne parce que
personne organisé le tournoi du coup il
espère via la wild-card trouver des
financements brouillard 8 on vous avoue
pourra jouer machin et tout mais c'est
que deux bases du gala à ce point ci
s'intéresse personne quoi genre
gérard roland garros même sur une page
web cartes de joueurs français il
organiserait parce que c'est quand même
cool qu'ils étaient des voix le quart de
ce que c'est normal et tu as de la
chance ou jour ton pays mais bon pour le
masters fin de saison de tennis a plu
doit être car quelques huit qualifiés et
pourtant d ici pas de franchise et bada
très longtemps en algérie sont pas la
dire maintenant si je ne peux pas
prendre mon joueur
80e mondiale dans le masters de 8000
heures mondiaux du n'organise pas
peut-être waroquet la norme alors ok
pour me des clous et après c'est bon ça
joue sous pression constamment choix de
la parfum c'est à mon agent m'a parlé de
jarry bon choix de la part de carrier
keynes que ça joue vraiment le cas à
fond est bon choix de la part de
champclause parce qu'au lieu de reculer
de 10 ferment jamais fermé à petit feu
ils envoient effet une partie normale
mais à vrai dire je pense que karine va
égaliser
malheureusement il a trop d'énergie
acier il a trop la position il est trop
plus fort qu'avant
après je sais qu'il est un deuxième
partie d'avant il m'a pas rassuré qu'en
fait il un peu perdue comme un bloc
après avoir très bien joué le coup mais
tout d'un coup organisant des candidats
est rentable pour les sponsors bajeux
pour les candidats je ne sais pas je
sais que d'après les chiffres que je
vois tous les tournois d'échecs
globalement c'est vraiment du mécénat et
ça peut pas être rentable parce que
enfin vu le rapport qualité prix du truc
ses fins en fait il ya trop d'argent à
dustin pour 0 public mais maintenant tu
vois je commençais un peu à connaître
avec les grosses audiences qu'on fait et
c est ce que tu peux en tirer enfin des
chiffres c'est trop démesuré on est
c'est peut-être d'une sans foi ou 1000
fois plus enfin tu peux avoir maintes
fois moins cher en fait je pense
donc en fait un ratio 1 x sens et c'est
beaucoup trop donc à mon avis c'est pas
possible
les candidats après il ya quand même un
prestige mais je pense que vu qu'à
chaque fois ils ont ils galèrent pour
trouver ils le font en russie que c'est
sûr financer un peu bizarrement la fois
c'est une région qui paient un
en quelque sorte donc je pense que ça
doit pas être rentable de toute façon
mettre plusieurs millions d'euros pour 0
public en présentiel et 15 20 milles sur
twitch ça paraît très disproportionnée
oui ce sont pour que ce soit rentable
après c'est plus du mécénat pour faire
plaisir c'est différent c'est une autre
vision quoi
après c'est mon point de vue un je ne
sais pas exactement jamais financé
d'événements comme ça mais par rapport à
ce que je peux voir ça me paraît très
fou jestin gagne pas une pièce pas
vraiment petit peu dommage 5
ils défendent fou à preuve c'est un coup
qu'on fera peut-être sûrement toute
façon tôt ou tard j'ai cinq prévenus
caillage 5 qui est mal placée en même
temps que te bloque des pions que tu as
tu veux le faire au meilleur moment où
tout garder 2 h 4 h 5
en fait qu'eric in his wife f 3h 4h 5,3
que nadja h3g qu'adil fait fiat pour
faire 5 et l'option foods g5
éventuellement que l'intrigué ajoutant
qu'il est mal
ouais mais ça peut amener de la détaxe
et des aides indirectes de la région qui
vont arriver
tous ces participants oui ça c'est vrai
tu prend de l'argent des impôts des gens
et tulle et de nos échecs non mais
grosso modo c'est non mais vous allez
taxer zaz et urwah impôts qui peut râler
pour teddy je vois pas ce que tu en
galère et tulle et donne pour un non
sens et sa fin mais pourquoi pas enfin
mais c'est pas rentable
c'est juste que tu tu crois à quelqu un
volant à quelqu'un d'autre
et oui mais pourquoi pas un nom mais je
sais pas c'est drôle mais c'est pas non
si c'est ça c'est un peu robin des bois
quoi parti fin de la marche ils sont
partis mais qui doit vraiment mettre le
coup de collier maintenant suivis de 10
carats n'avait pas avoir plus carré
final et fils et qu'elle serait le bon
système beaucoup de c'est difficile à
dire mais un système qui ramène plus de
public très clairement après il faut
déjà faire le bon diagnostic pour poser
pour donner le bon traitement quoi mais
si on part du point de vue qu'il faut
que les échecs devienne un sport
médiatique et financé plus ou moins
normalement debout coiffeur ya beaucoup
à faire mais il faudrait on va dire
s'occuper un peu plus du public et des
gens qui regardent et un peu moins des
gens qui défendent leurs petits intérêts
communs c'est ça
des revenus la fameuse petite marche je
gagne quelques hectomètres face à
etienne bacrot c'était vraiment une
grave erreur pour lui hier une polo
départage xxème siècle était retransmis
non je pense pas qu'il y ait en fait
transférer télé n'en a pas de futur
espace kim je suis pas aussi con c'était
les phisheurs les russes à se faire
livrer dans un monde différent révolte
n'est pas internet en fait tu avais pas
enfin même la télé tu as peut-être trois
chaînes fameux schéma en fait je ne sais
pas tu avais pas à tnt quoi la clac et
une chaîne comme l'équipe 21 quoi qui
peut être des échecs ça peut à l'époque
c'était que
que tf1 la 2 la 3 antennes de ce
tailleur et fr3 attiches chômé des
échecs
bref quattro
l'équipe mariés ont dit que leur record
d'audience c'est la pétanque en même ça
m'étonne pas un
ils ont bien su s'adapter se
révolutionner banon ont fait des grosses
audiences avec les échecs en français
sur twitter aussi et c'est sûr que si on
a adapté vraiment les formats au public
on pourrait vraiment sûr de voir
beaucoup de monde wes a très clairement
dit que d'appeler tant que tueur du
monde qui regarde si vous populaire et
d'ailleurs est ce que ça passe non je
crois que c'était un toqué d'ailleurs si
ça passe pas sport olympique en 2004 non
je crois pas alors que ça pourrait
savourer plus que les échappements
l'esprit moi j'aurais plutôt mis la paix
tant que médecin je t'adresse damassine
qu'au hockey il vous prend à deux ou
aussi virer son cavalier faire froncer 3
1 6 6 a besoin ok
sur eurosport le stocker aussi à
beaucoup cartonné vrai mais c'est plus
dynamique que les échecs le souk à ça
dépend elle est partie rapide ces
dynamiques généralement non mais en fait
après ya juste un truc soissons qui sera
inhérents c'est que le gars ça restera
toujours plus facile à comprendre que
les échecs se tient jamais joué à les
échecs tu sais vraiment pas ce qu'ils
font c'est une voie là après après je
pense et échecs jungbum il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui sont mises entre ça
sympa et donc il faut partir du principe
que faisait de bien faire et qu'il ya
quand même des gens qui regarderont
alors peut-être ça sera pas le foot
j'aime pas peut-être fera pas le foot tu
auras moins d'audience mais mettez pas
obligés de rester très bas quoi tu peux
progresser
bah oui mais c'est sûr que tu auras
jamais tout le monde parce que les gens
que ça va vraiment pas joué ils vont
garder un oeil un peu
ils seront mis en garde tient il joue
vite machin sans trop comprendre mais tu
peux pas nombreuses à 5 heures mais ils
peuvent regarder un peu et puis après
traduction ce passionné qui vont
apprendre qu'ils vont apprendre à
connaître les joueurs fausse idée d tête
d'affiche que les gens connaissent les
joueurs si une histoire que machin là en
france on a quand même vers camara
giroud cha on a quand même des arguments
à faire valoir et puis on a déjà
beaucoup de gens qui suivent donc ce
serait théoriquement possible mais
évidemment pouvoir faire un pape on a
ventes auraient besoin de virer les
cadences lente et de faire un vrai cycle
mondial en rapide c'est la condition
sinequanone mais cette condition elle
sera pas remplie dans la décennie à
venir est donc resté au fond de la baie
crabe alors atteint non latins petit
bien je bouge bien bien pourquoi donc
lachance partie 15 + 10 ou quelque chose
comme ça se plaint pas du deux minutes
dont plus de cinq minutes je pensais
trop court le but c'est un peu trop
court 25 plus 6 et un poêlon quelque
chose entre 15 et 20 + 10 1 15 10 15
c'est bien heures 40 45 minutes c'est
vraiment le format émission télé tu vois
par exemple une très bonne émission télé
touche pas à mon poste a vraiment très
très fructueuse je pense à 45 minutes
way généralement c'est à dire désolé je
regarde tous les soirs quand je
l'appelle fap sur les coups de torches
votre réponse réponse très bien rien
match de saint-etienne en amical tu sais
match amical c'est retransmis sur une
chaîne locale
c'est que si tu vis à saint-etienne que
tu peux vraiment bien sûr d'autres lois
d'ailleurs c'est la pâle équipe adultes
et les jeunes tu sais c'est moins de 14
ans est vraiment que nous qui regardons
dans un bus qui vont jouer en équipe une
on n'a personne faut bien les regarder
il faut aussi d'abriter les gouttes en
échec si on commence à diffuser un pull
en public c'est ce qu'on a commencé à
faire en fait voir sonne tout ça déjà je
crois que le problème c'est qu'en fait
on peut pas réussir seuls parce que on
peut réussir seul à faire ce qu'on a
fait mais on peut difficilement faire
plus parce que comme vous voyez pour
organiser un gros ton eau déchets un
gros temps à des chats il faut plusieurs
millions d'euros de budget à nouveau
prendre un design organisé en plus il
faudrait refondre faire une refonte du
circuit pour qui un titre mondial au
bout donc il faudrait il faudrait des
sommes astronomiques et nous on peut on
les a pas quoi juste maintenant on peut
rien y faire
kadja pourquoi pas mais là le coup qu'on
étire ses 5,5 et h5
c'est chaud quoi si on prend des six
sangles
c'est compliqué je trouve on va dire
ouais sèchement lors d'ide en gagnant
pour les blancs juste pour vous dire
mais c'est fou pays 6,9 à riom temps il
faut bien que d'abord je retarde à
manger sain qu'il faut approuver 5c pour
empêcher un homme proche des 5 es fou
pays si ce n'est de faire demain car d2
seul coup c'est pas pourquoi me prendre
les deux qui est des cinq seul coup elle
c'est introuvable ou fat et l'on prend
est humain non monsieur
ok si je trouve ça c'est un peu comme
contre maxime c'est un même fait un
bravo après ça pète le seul truc mais
c'est très dur même en longue d'ailleurs
rapide
non mais tu donnes trop de matériel et
pour un match qui allait incertain au
quotidien
donc à ces 5 à 6 c'est vraiment très
très dur non c'est incroyable non mais
tu peux le trouver au feeling pas tu
peux arriver à la position b 5
oui mais du coup tu as peut-être
d'autres d'autres trucs à tenter ici
bien sûr mais j'ai en fait tu peux aussi
par hasard parce que quand il a fait le
fou prend h4 contre maxime fait il un
bol pas possible avec aria linda
ouardane des 5 et tout le week end y
voir des trucs entre franche 4 clément
et là je quasi tempo mais si je
convaincs toi c'est ça ma pole a
vraiment joué
quel système politique à tenter la
barque et il a tout trouvé et je leur
parle il a quand même de la réussite
après il est très fort d'avoir tout
trouvé mais il a quand même de la
réussite
après il faut diffuser les tours 1-2
rapide de blitz sur l'équipe ou alors
ils l'ont déjà fait canal + sport ils
ont déjà commentée du temps à de rapides
et ils ont arrêté les slovènes n'avait
pas marché mais pas de façon délégué
puis aussi sur dailymotion ou wade à 300
400 personnes
en fait le truc oui l'équipe n'avait
fait le truc tu savais pas mal c'était
l'équipe tv web 1 s'était pas l'équipe
tv télé mais c'est déjà bien mais après
c'est plus la compétition qui se fussent
freerider coeur et la forme à la
compétition il c'était trop long trop
dur à combat comprendre le grand fils
est sur la même erreur en fait qu'on
fait systématiquement format de plus un
peu bizarre les matches étaient trop
durs à comprendre y ait trop de partis
en même temps se perdent et le domaine
est toujours comme toujours mauvais
format balle frôler en fait ces deux
jamais de prendre la vie de quelqu'un un
peu extérieur des échecs bannu pas rend
plus fort mâcon avec les deux chaises
bras sur l'a7 battle en 4 contre 4 ça
c'est genre d' excellent format pour un
truc comme l'équipe tv leur exemple le
mot elle sait que tu prends jamais la
vie des gens qui font des choses qui
marchent feront toujours la vie de gars
dans des bureaux qui soit fait du
copinage qui savent pas aussi vont te
rapporter des voix des machins
un fait qu'a ta tête
j'aimerais fait dodo ta vie et tu
connais rien mais du coup à chaque fois
les forêts qui sont trop dur à
comprendre pour le grand public quand tu
fais des trucs qu'il dise pas que le
cast est mauvais dit c'est pas mal mais
juste c'était trop dur à suivre parce
que c'est du quatre contre quatre les
quatre partis en même temps et que ça va
trop vite et qu'on n'arrive pas à suivre
cariat qui n'ont su aller mon ami à la
chante la cjs que franco ne sait pas
qu'il ya autour de supporters en france
c'est pas qu'on allait tous fort
changeant la faune sinon c'est pas je
vote soit on le connaît pas ben moi j'ai
une fois conduit à gibraltar avec
quelques années mais je lui parle jamais
quoi c'est moi qui parle français il
parle un peu dingo français bien j'ai
envoyé une invit six qualifiés aux
candidats pour la vitrine cup non pour
découvrir l'interview champions
peut-être pour rejoindre l'équipe en jeu
explique qu'on sait pas de châssis qui
ont écrit hier il faut informer
complètement claqué au sol mais moi j'ai
rien compris en lice je te jure j'ai
compris mais ils ont dit on vous enverra
plus de détails ce que c'est peut-être
pas très compréhensible pour être là
faut plus quatre joueurs il en faut neuf
alors déjà pourquoi neuf joueurs c'est
énorme joueur
puis en fait au début tu es une arena
avec neuf joueurs de son équipe contre
d'autres fins
j'ai apprête à un match en quatre
comptes qu'à fin c'est n'importe quoi
c'est un truc bien de base et j'ai lu le
truc je me suis même demandé si on
allait le faire ou pas c'est sur un jour
par contre seulement 1 jouera c'est fini
tu peux te qualifier tu as une qualif
sur un jour et après j'ai pas compris ce
que c'était mais d'un truc qui était
assez bien ils ont réussi à faire un
truc et comprend une usine à gaz
ouais avec trois formats de match
différent qui continue tu marques tu
dépends enfin c'est n'importe quoi c'est
tellement dommage
et pourquoi pas faire une fois par
semaine juste sur un jour savez toute la
journée tu vas devoir jouer à fond enfin
j'étais dégoûté après ils m'ont dit que
cette saison c'est être un truc écho
plus mais cassant prochaine salle est
bien là ce sera bien de son temps
ouais les grands prix pca et les
trophées immo par sexe ça fonctionnait
assez bien du coup cet été ses marchés
beaucoup trop bien pourquoi pas j'ai
cinq ans on a montré en fait un saillant
très complexe ce après ça marche mais je
vais lui dire la turbine est mais sinon
allez mon ca me voyez la sam nom m'a
fait faire g5 tf6 soit c'est un truc
intuitif mais [ __ ] pour tout calculé
enfin que voudrait que quand tu es là ok
faut ici c'est logique ils te prends des
cases et tu te dis pas qu'on choisit
d'attaquer mais là pour trouver et
précise et directe juste pour ça c'est
fou les systèmes logiques il revient ça
peut-être tu vas me souviens que c'est
leur choix mais ça peut-être tu me dis
tout bloqué il écoule merde attends je
pense qu'il ya un coût puisque quand il
ya un truc qui bouge bizarre on affiche
toujours on s'est pris le bug non ne me
prendrait six ans il a joué là
bafé g5 ff5 non il a déjà fait beaucoup
d'autres ok c'est un coup pas mal
il suffit d'enlever la vie de la dame
dont il veut faire du sport qui pourtant
clan hawiye met d'accord enfin ça c'est
pas mal à celle ci trouve ça beaucoup
d'attention la mission est mais bon nous
on verrait content on a voulu fois
j'insiste maxime il serait bon train
avec fait de vrai mais ça va pas mal
forcément ça va à l'encontre de chant
basse si karine gagné ses six chambres
championnat français pal moi je continue
et mais bon c'est vrai que c'est chiant
saddam c'est le pari fou quand même car
est au contact du x 2 donc tu peux pas
partir où tu veux et à la taknaw cette
même date après que deux fois dont une
en place dames 1 4 il a pas beaucoup de
casse pour partir une fois on fait
passer pas mal fou deux et on fait
comment si sa paire bon on joue là bas
en fait on va y aller après l'armageddon
mais si ça casse le rêve parce qu'enfin
il remarche en plus un ami m'a dit si tu
as duda et carrier qui nos candidats ça
fait des vrais candidats comme ça
dégoûte
alors que là on était très bien et je
suis un clan de feydeau cf parmi eux on
en place est déjà quand on envoyé en
éclaireur 6 juin demi après on avait un
shot dans le match pour la troisième
place
obama doit battre une scène
ouais mais bon il n'y a pas de chance
mais bon qui sait on peut faire à les
calculs très bien il a fait les killers
sitting donc très fort en calcul
non mais c'est pas une grande partie de
championnat
oui mais bon la garde il a dit qu il est
très fort en calcul pas du tout étonnée
par ces résultats
donc là il calcula fonds est rien je
calcule fous je fais les exercices
quelques beaucoup mieux que soi
très beau qu'on paye un abonnement à
maximo killer celle sing sing
et oui mais on a vu que ça des très bons
résultats shankland la communauté qui se
cotisent pour te payer un abonnement
quoi de quoi à maxime jeu qui va se les
entendons de la garde à vue dont on lui
envoie ouais c'est la cohue qui va
secondes et maxime à vincent de 20 noms
et on va aller on va lui payer le truc
qui est bon faut aller il faut bien
entraînés score que son clan mais avant
très bien très beau après mystic locales
ont dit oui vraiment très important car
si je regarde si on installe oui je suis
pas du tout étonnée je lé 8 avril calcul
vraiment très bien tu as tes petits
meetings une fois par semaine ou tu
viens dire oui j'ai calculé sa machine
est tout content et très heureux dans
des colons ligne quoi mais après je sais
très mécontent il s'interdit d'utiliser
un ordinateur
oui pour aller sur des exercices parce
qu'ils décrivent ces sert à rien mais je
dois quand même mais bon les gens s'ils
veulent faire raser comme utilise
ordinateur en blitz choses comme ça sert
à rien mais c'est beau quand même de
bien te préciser on te donne des
exercices mais il faut pas à tricher
avec l'ordinateur
mais la raison en fait fin c'est un
fléau ce truc ce serait géré moi-même
quand physiques ou des exercices des
élèves québécois c'est juste pas posée
qui trouve tout ça il va je connais leur
niveau je vois les difficultés du truc
bon ben il faut compter encore trop avec
l'ordi metal l'histoire me disent j'ai
trouvé il a fait reculer donc ça permet
cahier des 5
je crois que c'est quand même bon
perdant
fera que celle avant qu'on a montré là
en plus le deuxième problème de caïds et
cinq bercy [ __ ] à défendre cette étude
fait bouffer ou 7 après tu te ranger
cinquième si cette fois je suis noir non
je crois que c'est mort
j'ai 5 ou 5 jeux pas lequel
et c'est qu'une option parmi tant
d'autres un bon en fait je vois pas ce
qui est bien en fait foi tu parles
froides aux cheveux rouges et 7 sinon
partie c'est terrible c'est le nom
partie complète quoi je suis dégoûtée
elle valait 10 et game qui est des cinq
ans j'y croyais un bas je pensais pas
qu'ils allaient faire des fonds 110 coup
je suis tellement dégoûté peu de la
merde ce qui est un exercice assez
réussi sa dette allemands du coeur
description de la vie
non mais l'impressionnant sky qui n'a
toujours gagné quand il est dos au mur
la lcbo lâchant quand il a compris qu'il
était prêtre à l'issue est pas lui qui a
été 5 je pense non mais là vu qu'ils
étaient cinglés du croire qu'ils
préfèrent un petit peu pas enfin sur
fond d 2 tu peux pas oublier qu'il ya
des 50 da d'ivoire d'amd vite c'est pas
possible il était dedans ma 4 enfin je
sais pas ce qu'il est bien possible que
oui dames 1 4% ce bizarre mais ça c'est
qu'il ya une morale ou trias bazooka et
prend des cinq je sais pas apparemment
ça marche il prend des cinq peut-être tu
bouffes ladder ils bouffent d'hommes du
feu tour prend b3 ou quoi j'ai besoin
d'un deuxième phase une b3 d'ailleurs là
mon sac puis visuellement malefoy de il
renvoie en fait la barbe frommer's
finito mais bon le truc c'est qu'il ya
plein de trucs qui vont pas dans cette
variante mp3 a gagné en fait ben on va
de 8 à pâques unis ne trouve pas que tu
joues tu es bien il marche il fait très
mal au cours de marches une tendance il
revient
j'ai oublié les pubs away genre est
plein là un pub à foucault jégo a de
l'envié est là faut que m dix minutes de
pub quoi mais surtout pendant la pause
bah j'en envoie déjà maintenant enfin on
peut pas se permettre
avant la pause y aura peut-être neuf
minutes de pub entre les deux parties
bonjour mais quand même six maintenant
pour assurer ce que j'ai oublié de
talent moi j'y pense pas toujours un
j'ai pas forcément leur est pas vraie
flex pub
après y'a pas tout le monde qui l'a en
fait quand tu envoies deux fois
normalement c'est pas les mêmes qui vont
la deuxième fois nous avons droit à deux
fois mais c'est des gens différents
la ligue des champions mais du coup ils
suis à fond avec les normes deux parties
terrible après entre les parties on peut
se faire une vraie pause en fait on peut
partir comme ça je mets les plafonds
souffle vous prendrez 5 attention il
faut des deux qui attaquent la dame
quand même c'est l'idée première des
blancs ce qui semblait attaque la dame
ils menacent sa et dans les problèmes
c'est lui là bas au coin le jour le
guerrier plus là mais en fait là il peut
pas repartir et le pion là il ya le
foulayah le pion lie à l'option donc il
est comme un plot ici se faire de
l'attaqué pour le cueillir quoi donc
c'est ça tous les problèmes des nord
cumulé qui font que priori a pas d'issue
enfin on n'en voit pas et l'ordi dit
qu'un n'a pas donc bon j'imagine que
c'est juste un rebond foutu
parti de merde là ouais je sais pas où
il a merdé sache n'est pas notre truc
mais je suis noir complètent enfin fois
de précis en fait peut-être fois aussi
sympa je sais pas enfin peut-être fort
ok peut-être je sais pas mais en fait
faut aussi ce il va lui faire ça de
façon stricte fort marne c'est pour
repartir tu as l'air d'un con on prendra
2 c'est d'ailleurs le truc logique tout
au bout de ses convictions mais tu perds
quoi maxime crise est mauvaise et en
vrai aux membres en pratique trop dur à
jouer
le spécialiste de la nage en a parlé et
on peut vraiment faire comme si les mecs
que peut-être je vous le redis à fond tu
t'en sors je sais pas comment mais
revenir dire histoire
tout le monde sait enfin dans le mariage
3 c'est une ligne pas mal enfin
secoue la tête en mai tandis qu'à se
motiver pour les pour les parties plus
rapide ensuite faire c'est ok c'est une
non partie se fait défoncer et puis
voilà un fou prend un sens il faut
prendre et quatre tours prend des cas
devait arriver à mettre son cavalier on
n'est pas je pense qu'il a vendu en deux
trois coups là il peut essayer de
bouffer un deuxième pion
ok ils compteront foutu et autres ok et
donc puisque tours 1 4 est ce que b 3 4e
très logiquement que killer châssis
strychnine carrick pour les prochaines
km et multi 0 la tondeuse jeu résolvez
les chaises qui leur estime qu'en que je
faisais la pelouse c'était vrai bon coup
car il claque qui va trouver le coup le
plus précis après deux tours à quatre
serres de tuer leur dis bravo aux droits
des deux qui est cool aussi
l'idée c'est de provoquer qui prend fou
prendre avec la tour et puis c'est le
tour à paris hier à la barre en fer mais
le fou de montres à quatre mois on n'a
pas de surprise on a encaissé ce truc
mais en même temps mais bon on va aller
de trois à quatre les deux sont très
bien votre alphabet 3 rue ce serait
peut-être pas mauvais à christophe mais
en fait tu as même pas besoin de coincer
vu qu'il est déjà coincé il n'ya pas de
cadre au tour mangés
là on contrôle et non contre en fait b3
souvent il faut le faire l'ambition
était là et qu'il faut aller en bref
cette série d'attaqués parce qu'il
partirait là pour le coup t'as pas
besoin de le coincer plus qui il est
déjà coincé après le seul intérêt de b3
c'est qui celui-là attaque peut-être
partir aussi peut-être te dire que cette
manne non il a essayé de lutter mais ça
que c'est que de pionsat la peur de fou
[Musique]
keane ancien précis portent ils pas fini
il faut faire gagner partie gagnante
pas toujours facile d'insulter à vrai
dire pour lui il peut pas dire je prends
de résultat pire nul parce que si tu
fais nul tu es éliminé 3-2
en fait c'est peut-être le coup j'aurais
fais moi si je si j'y pense juste parce
que eux d'avoir la tour des quatre ans à
deux mal placé études il est bien au
centre et c'est mon autour de merde qui
rend à deux mais d'autres seront très
bien je trouve plus logique a priori
c'est un peu moins précis d'après la
turbine mais son appareil comme le coup
le plus plus logique quoi donc tu
valides dont je valide
axe fort mentalement pour revenir était
mené deux fois bah ouais mais surtout
car yakine s'est imposé son point fort
dans toute sa carrière ce côté mental il
est parente allemand ouais il ya une
coupe du monde qu'il a gagné jusqu'en
2015 je pense qu on a fait une vidéo
d'un ils étaient menés face et la finale
est en quatre parties à l'époque qui
était mené 2-0 quoi là c'est pas gagné
une partie il fallait c'était en gagner
deux juste pour revenir à égalité encore
avait gagné départager après je crois
que nous ne les départage sartre revenez
fait chez pas c'est son truc il a il va
très vite et doit gagner
bon voilà c'est nul ils avaient de
meilleur ouverture bay s'est fait
marcher dessus avec la française donc
peut-être j'ai pas envie de retourner
dans quoi non mais en fait c'est très
dur de donner un conseil sur con tu dois
faire nul parce qu'un cantal et noir
enfin que les blancs bon t'as des
petites idées tu faire comme carl
sagnières par exemple mais avec les
blancs avec les barbares dont tu es
censé être un peu moins bien quoi tu
joues quoi donc soit tu fais un truc que
tu souffres à long terme peut-être aura
une finale un peu chiante ou quoi soit
tu fais une partie de combat et c'est
pas qu on fait de lancer un combat juste
leila match d'ouverture en fait c'est
pas que la neige a refait réfutées comme
ça non plus mais hier la française il a
pris l'eau complètement s'il fait 4,5
bon je sais pas si c'est vraiment un ces
répertoires ou quoi mais pourquoi pas
mais battus à de prendre une petite
italienne et espagnole tu vas pas fermé
en claquant des doigts quoi tu joues une
berlinoise la finale je fais pas nul
comme ça où on peu trop fut la finale de
faire des 3 ou je sais pas quoi donc
la campagne ne fait pas nul à la demande
après évidemment les ici viennent c'est
sans cette puce est désolant tire un peu
de combat mais fréquentes et très bien
préparé je suis pas sûre ce sera moins
un nul en qu'une autre après il faut
être très bien préparé le reste et ça en
fait si si tu te prend le bouillon comme
la dans la partie et sympa cette
série-là a perdu moins vite en jouant de
4,5 chose est sûre je veux la pire quoi
la pire que c'est justement ça le truc
toujours pour essayer déséquilibré gerba
qui quand ils étaient menés contre pur
rhône
il a joué une moderne dernière que c'est
la même famille tu fais ça mais non il
pour faire nul tu fais pas trop la pire
quoi tu te faut un peu dans la merde
dans un pire que je veux dire provoque
notre avis un peu t'attaquer et tu veux
contre et 1 mn de jeu un truc et donc ça
une b3 maintenant parce que tout de
suite ça se donner la case c4 et puis
ils veulent attaquer ensuite le fou qui
va faire pas même commentaire qu'avec
toutes les ventes karo kann c'est très
bien c'est solide
il servait une recette miracle pour
faire ni avec les noirs les échecs
n'existerait plus en fait oui ça serait
plus rien dans les blancs tournefeuille
la même variante l ouverture et dire à
tout le temps d'une et puis quand on en
parle plus quoi ce serait beau bas des
coûts place à 960 oui mais là peut-être
qu'ils retiennent pas tout
petrov a new wave et rohff c'est pas con
mais pareil petrov t'es pas sur un mais
oui petrov
oui on nommé par nature légué peut pas y
avoir une ouverture une sorte de reims
sinon il ya plus de jeu et les blancs
ils vont toujours pressé après ça se
joue au mental ça se joue à moi j'ai
trouvé que son choix de jouer ce qu'il
avait prévu assez bon c'est pas con
c'est pas con pas ils sont venus après
coup on peut dire un mauvais choix mais
pas plus mal qu'un autre fait très vite
ces pièces de moi mais je trouve ça pas
mal en fait de jouer une partie d'échecs
eu juste jouer que pour faire nul assez
en fait tu essaies de jouer des coups
que tu penses être les meneurs tout le
long alors pour faire nul tu fais frein
à main fram un frein à main tu veux
finir par perdre la force de gm avant
c'est un peu comme un certain peter
l'écho vous oui j'ai pas encore mis la
vidéo en ligne mais syndrome karpov
avait eu quand ils menaient 12 ans que
kasparov ou des choses comme ça que je
voulais jouer sans perdre après eh oui
quand il veut c'est exact et et
s'épargner des genres qui arriverait
très bien en fait nous dira je dois
faire nul de chez nul franquart et je
bouge pas une oreille et qui montrent la
tenir et ils peuvent soutenir d'être un
peu moins bien longtemps d'autres c'est
pas du tout leurs trucs et de vouloir
jouer aux échecs comme jean claude a
fait bas qui se connaît il a fait son
choix mais il a mal joué l'ouverture en
fait un autre problème en fait c'est pas
c'est pas le choix de l'ouverture le
problème c'est de la manière dont il l'a
joué parce qu'il est nul voila il n'a
pas bien fait son exercice tels que
chess machine sting couverture mais
c'est un bon exclamé d'ouverture c'est
très bonne version
c'est tellement dur
rebaïne cubain allait oublier en fait
trois minutes encore ouais mais bon
quand je suis à pas tous eu un patron de
k 3 minutes et puis de toute façon c'est
obligé entre les partis c'est de la
grosse pumain ah bah oui ça appartient
on a quand même beaucoup moins nombreux
et incroyables plus bas qui a grillé
plus les français
c'est moins intéressant est brouillée
lâchant que là quand même c'est à dire
combien on est trois mille messages
encodés une première page twitter c trés
peu du coup mais peut-être 1500 2000 en
réalité après la pub elle vient pas au
pire mon non plus puisque la partie à
vrai dire passe vraiment pas grand chose
bah ouais bah on attend que karine
gagnon après passif est le coût ryanair
a peint mais ces bassins foot+
alors certes il ya deux pions mais c'est
pas des pions passé qui avance sont bien
regroupés
mon petit à petit il a fait le taf pour
seconde rangée dans un petit coup de
fouet des deux pour pas le laisser
partir en âge de faire du foot et 2
est tombé quattro samba qui je ne suis
pas épanoui vraiment personne ne la qua
non mais moi je suis pareil comme en
fait qu'il y ait plus de joueurs que je
supporte jeu rage quit la plupart des
compétitions que je regarde c'est pas
toi avant vab association fait refaire
les graves quand il a peut être fait des
nanas [ __ ] on utilise wimbledon où
l'on a tous le score comme sabatiera
s'agit là c'est bien où il a perdu ou
ailleurs tout ça c'est un event
qualificatif géré si c'était pour aller
en finale deux des candidats de pour
aller jouer contre carl scène et que
c'est la finale tête je regarde tous
âges en finale de wimbledon je peux
regarder non mais comme carl cette
époque car ses défauts mais je vais
regarder avec plaisir
oui bon c'est un gros match ou quoi être
un journal de canal window foot même si
en valeur cardinale sinon on n'exigeait
pas regardé par contre à la fin je vais
être de retour en fait mais je vais pas
être de retour en quarts de finale d'un
événement qualificatif
un qualificatif cette date il qualifie
même pas pour le gros truc tu te
qualifies pour te qualifiée d'hostile
des classes ça veut pas suivre beaucoup
de tourner vers des liens et puis après
des équipes que j'aime pas quand j'avais
déjà envie de les voir perdre ça c'est
aussi autre chose
jeanne intérêt alors tu vois tu peux
suivre en dix ans et je déteste vraiment
vu que c'était face au collège avec des
champions je suis avec grand intérêt la
demi-finale de city par exemple j'étais
très heureux match à ça je sais pas trop
je fais mon truc
sa coque open perdue comme j'ai pu mais
une fois que j'ai plus mes joueurs une
fois que j'ai pu mais équipe ça qui est
bien avec le cyclisme ce qu'être même
sucer qui peut gagner le tour de france
tu peux gagner une étape c'est qu'il a
gagné mais tu dis oui bon il ya encore
les étapes et du maillot rose
enfin le maillot à pois surtout pour
volgelsheim il doit être un peu déçu tu
pourras pris le meilleur à méfier des
goûters créé les maillots rapport en
fait donné pour qui le mieux la page
et tandis que des miettes quoi et je
pensais qu'il a fait pour le coup la
demi finale cette année ce n'était pas
lui on lui on lui on lui on lui on n'y
avait pas de problèmes qu enfin même ils
ont fait un parcours c'était bien leur
match dans le final final eight là quand
il rencontre le bayern défunt gros match
mais quand j'étais plus jeune en fait je
comprenais pas trop se délient et puis
après non non non je vous réponds pas je
pense que c'est vraiment débile cas
pourquoi pourquoi pas les aimer enfin je
m'en fout en fait fin je me faire mon
propre avis et c'est juste au stade avec
les banderoles les machins vont tu peux
prendre des trucs plus à coeur tu dis
bon ok c'est mes ennemis sont mes
ennemis c'est comme ça c'est le folklore
mais je peux pas de pourquoi et quand
même oui c'est comme ça il faut que leur
fallait enfin pour moi ya pas de vrais
noms seront fou mais en fait le problème
fournir le problème c'est pas les gens
comme toi ce que toi tu comprends que
c'est une injection stupidité mais tu
dois être contre en fait face est comme
ça et vice versa il
[Musique]
mais il faut pas que ça n'est pas ça
c'est un jeu un sport enfin ce qu'on
veut et puis voilà quoi donc tu peux ça
peut être marrant du chambrage du truc
c'est un peu content mais enfin des fois
oui ça dépasse tout entendement c'est
n'importe quoi à l'étranger moi aussi je
peux être un peu mais je sais pas en
espagne que j'aime le barça donc comme
ça je pas pourquoi angleterre j'aimais
bien manchester united
maintenant je m'en fous les plus jeunes
je vais bien quand il avait comme mur tu
as tient donc à et beckham giggs scholes
tous âges étaient comptés important et
mairesse a commencé a pu être trop
poteau et à karak jamais compris comment
ce joueur fouet respecter en fait bon
ben spies et six militaires comme
carrick jamais respecté
guillaume je suis lyonnais j'ai même
patienter je sais pas pourquoi mais
c'est juste obligé même c'est en fait
juste objet de paris mais en fait c'est
comme ça tu n'aimes pas tu aimes pas
enfin
mais c'est très con en vrai bref le film
maudit par ailleurs patron c'est comme
ça boit ça t'aide rivalité sportive vous
donne enfin en fait ça arrêtez d'être
bonne
ça c'est dommage mais alors là c'est
juste du semis troll machin mehiaoui et
donc est ce que je raconte j'aime tout
vous trouvez un cas qui est un message
anti kane et femmes seulement quelques
lots que vous suit mais après avoir subi
beaucoup de personnes dans différents
domaines en plusieurs langues je peux
connaître grand vous avez tout mon
respect je vous souhaite longue et roux
dans ce que vous entreprenez merci en
partie pour le plus grand bonheur merci
à toi ça fait trois jours que je vous
suis mais non mais il a senti mais il a
senti j'ai tout si j'ai tout de suite su
neuf c'est bien je pense que quand matt
cassel c'est dimanche déjà demain
cerveau
vous étiez en train de griller un petit
à petit un ouais faut définir le taf
mais oui c'est sûr qu'il aime il ya
toujours sont fous de plus en plus
peut-être pour créer des masses tour du
roy sous toutes ces cases noires et
c'était un coin complexe l'ol n'a qu'une
seule rivalité les stéphanois les autres
c'est de l'artificiel mais pour le coup
en fait je suis demandé mais en fait
vous aimeriez quand même que s'intéresse
tant lien pour qu'il y ait mai dernier
chaque année la jarre qui soit très nul
face 17e qui suit vous êtes heureux mais
vous savez plaisir qu'ils aillent en
ligue 2 ou même qui disparaissent
généralement très brillant leader suis
pas sûr fasse tout pour sortir peut-être
eux qui ont elles en lui donnant un
groupe de 23 sur le coup tu peux dire à
vous êtes très bien mais en fait fait
c'est bien qu'ils avaient remis comme le
schtroumpf est content tout et de
majorer saison en touche on va les
herbiers et il veut qu'il soit un peu je
devais la tête sous le derby mais voilà
il ya pas grand chose il ya du rajoutant
un peu qui nous book 5004 hall n'y a pas
si longtemps c'était le cas mdr oui mes
yeux le cas dans le sens aussi enfin
vous aimerez pas avoir un derby en ligue
des champions dans un truc un peu au
dessus bah je pense on aimerait bien
mais faso ce que nous on est là en fait
sainté lyon en ligue des champions ça
aurait vraiment de la gueule non
about him france mais qui gagne il faut
il fait un truc bien non mais nous on
n'est pas près d'y aller la ligue des
champions déjà qu'on se maintienne
on va suivre encore quelques saisons qu
on n'a pas de budget on n'a rien reçu
on voit que ça défend on voit qu'à leur
niveau en fait pièce de plus c'est pas
simple un bail se veut un pont champlain
s'agira ici car c'est une paire de mains
contre né pauvre il a fallu mon truc
alors sa qualification candidat est
nécessaire mais non mais en fait il sera
qualifié si vous fermez le match vous
êtes façon qualifiés aux candidats
d'autant que j'ai postulé récit pensent
encore qu'il doit absolument battre
doute à demain on retrouve au prochain
tour pour aller aux candidats mais même
s'ils perdent le match sera au candidat
mais je me rends compte en fait il ya
beaucoup de gens qui comprennent pas en
argument parce qu'ils savent que la
règle connaissent pas les règles
clairement supérieur à sainté il monte
en ligue 1 à terme ce sont des sondes
pitot équipe sympathique soit lancé très
énervé par ce qui a plu au monde qui
arrive et qui vaut au stade au rugby ou
un truc comme ça nous avons clairement
favorite munichois oui enfin à vous
votre un peu de foot mais oui aussi un
joueur clermont foot des plus forts que
clermont guy temps ont changé
des boas le derby cannes nice à l'époque
mais c'était vraiment n'importe quoi
c'est pas du tout banni ce prix est une
bonne équipe de foot ouais puis après
ils ont coulé quoi mais bon c'est pas
fin à la ville est trop petite c'est pas
fait pour ça formé au milk ou 8 à 70 ans
il ya peu il ya peu d'équipés dans des
villes de 70000 habitants puis c'est pas
une ville qui voit sa faillite il ya
d'autres choses quoi ce pas une ville
faite pour nous c'est le volet ouais
ouais bof ça le féminin sinon ouais les
deux vraies
il y avait dû garder ainsi qu'à pas
donné grand-chose frais frei un proche
de feu derrière
oui mais il n'a pas en fait je
m'attendais à ce qu'il devienne cette
équipe de france ou quoi c'est qui l'a
pas fait mais était apparemment après
parme et la fiorentina
il a fait une belle cadence et rien en
fait je crois qu'il était vraiment
respecté en italie en fait c'est un des
bons gars de série à
très bien quand ils 7000 habitants oui
mais bon c'est différent un gagnant
c'est fou en fait c'est encore ligue 1
non mais on monte on sait enfin ils sont
là ils menacent quoi si elle était ravie
a juste une équipe qui au courant genre
nice om nice et si ça fait marseille ils
ont déjà fait partie de mon envie de les
battre
c'est fou et de les battre et c'est
toujours un match de gala donc lui
rendre est allé battre
j'ai toujours mes de rémy mais a fait
marseille 7 rempli ton stade fait
toujours ton petit match de gala machin
rémy macadam et il coûte il joue pas mal
il en fait c'est pas c'est un joueur de
club
quoi donc il joue et des fulgurances
mais il fait il fait des trucs bien il
peut avoir un niveau où il peut te
battre des joueurs à 2000 ou plus ou
faire des pas des conneries mais il est
capable quoi jugan ce métier là mais
maintenant il fait son petit système de
long on y passe bien c'est rudy qui se
développe si peu de dégâts sur les
tactiques enfin est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il ya sept ans il peut aussi avoir
des absences mais en face il faut un peu
comme maxime chercher 2 des finales très
technique maxime aussi des finales il me
voilà absence mais rémy il est venu
faire des tournois pendant un rapide et
tourna kilkenny il adore les échecs
georgia je veux toujours en amateur qui
adore le jeu qui suit qui aime bien la
fin de la game pas le truc c'est qu'il
va faire fou et 6,5 pour des visites
échangées revenir et mathé je suis très
bien que des vitres et instinct me
demande mais fait il veut revenir vers
et 6 et prendre l'air du roi des cinq
tours 17 après plutôt juste pas se
rendre tous rêvent de mais bon
coupe au tour de chant une tour bat il
pourra le faire plus tard mais c'est une
grappe lui faire aussi
avec les échecs je dois dire c'est un
jeu comme c'est quand même long même en
rapide du monde fondamentalement des
fans ont fondamentalement d'être pour un
joueur on se sent vraiment s'y
intéresser rapide non mais je n'ai en
fait quand et pour un joueur genre t'es
un baquet ambulants web et que ça dans
l'émotionnel
ça paraît pas long mais c'est vrai que
ce genre de finale quand c'est des
joueurs bons et h en club mais a vite
fait c'est vrai que ça paraît vraiment
l'on veut bien se débrouiller et la pub
encore bah oui enfin faut envoyer un nom
cela je pense bientôt on pourra mettre
dix minutes défilent et s'être encore
mieux aux banques on en voit en
prophylaxie 1
du coup tout ce qu'on veut vraiment ravi
au bon moment il se voudrait pas
totalement d'accord en tant qu assume
mais pas quand on a quasiment fait en
tant que tout le monde enfin là tu as
deux heures de match
la partie a duré une heure s'est enfin
parce que là où vrai on connaît résultat
depuis quarante minutes des beats bien
que non mais qu un fils dans un bassin
bientôt 10 n'a fini qu'à nos jeunes
également ça va être bien mais en plus
tu vas leur dise au plus bas et ça fait
vraiment éclaté très vite rien mais il a
raison car et qui n'a pris de prendre
son temps et championnat raison de jouer
en fait il ya des endroits où vous
entendre
béatrice top les pions il est utile pour
ces cinq échecs pour du coup je pomme je
pense qu'il allait ramasser en fait va
mettre l'option au sein qui va aller
ramasser avec sept tours et à faire le
petit a appris les changera il enverra
le pion
et dix minutes entre les deux parties
c'est exactement ça la plus basse la
réclame attendez ça change une tour
il a vu encore quoi comme parti ensuite
ba2 en dix minutes
c'est encore un partout de en blitz si
un grain partout un armageddon
jce et tft qui s'est pris 14 nuls de
suite après tu peux peut-être faire
juste faux f6 tour bouge et surtout
razer cinq essais dès le matin j'avais
dit ça photo mc c'est à bahia plus trop
d'espoir pour jean clamon goffette sais
pas s'il va remonter fait là il est
devant il mène
iman a élagué la première sa main mais
[Musique]
elle va se faire égaliser pas on attend
cet endroit ce 3 13h05 paraît logique et
ça allait dans la mare en tout il va
récupérer le plomb j'essaie de vous
allez le voir à 8,8 à tour des 3 à 8 ans
des trois essais matt usine ici partie
de l'autre côté ça c'est matt est ici à
partir de l'autre côté c'est la variante
dont on vous parlait évidemment c'est un
marché new line et bon vraiment les
pieds on peut faire tout ça bon du coup
une petite pause tâche de pub la salle
ont donc à la peau grâce à tout va ça de
diesse mythos
vas-y je renvoie une pub en est que par
trois huit mais je repasse m'ont envoyé
au dessus des gambiens dans 10 minutes
pour le pour le prochain match
son cas allait la quitter à l'eba qui
shalalala à l'eba qui lalalalalala à
baky ouais bah qui bat kibaki bas qui
bat kibaki
c'est au coach angevin tous les tournois
quand il ya le chalet pas qui serait
beau quand je suis allé voir un tournoi
en vrai un grandes chaussures ou quoi
les affiches baky et vous envoyez un
ballet baki ah oui ça serait énorme que
tu en seras viré détour paquets les
fumeurs à l'eba qui est jean yves on
joue encore baky non mais on se parle
enfin et baky quoi c'est parti à nos
forfaits sicilienne quoi il a pu
peut-être aider ces petits fichiers avi
savar 35 faut envoyer les pâquis bas
kibaki à sargans sg 4 hier étouffe les
couacs du beaucoup courir pour faire ces
trucs et que pense jean rémillard fait
quoi tu penses sur le tour de france
l'an prochain
on peut tenter alors détenteur d'actions
organisée à un truc bike si j'ai pas on
va sur un vent tout quoi et on fait
aller va quitter si nous filons commun
aller le presque au pakistan indépendant
et avec les draps boudin blanc est
toujours extraordinaire franchement
c'est franchement c'est magnifique
chanson peut le faire on est assez con
pour y arriver non à des boums
on a des cyclistes bas qui cette année
avec un nouveau truc whiting qu'aux
partis d'avancer tout bon il a juste
fait une entrée scoop assez convaincant
et c'est bien j'ai failli changer te
connaît
non c'est un bon tournoi et pour
supporter bas qui ont balancé fish qui
peut être soit avec les subissent non en
fait l'an prochain ses grandes chez soi
est ouvert à paris et qui encore baky
franchement peu se motiver on y va à 100
non mais on monte vraiment on y va à 100
et on fait ont fait l'animation à l'eba
qui va en voir jamais réussi à faire ils
vont jamais comment sait-on un maximum
de bruit taisez-vous est très content
mais j'imagine que ce temps libre mais
j'imagine pas qui c'est pas possible
d'être non à chaque fois qu'il ait
toujours à dubaï la semaine on revient à
la leçon la jamaïque lui et tous les
temps d'arrêt que c'était un peu partout
tout le temps que la la peña macky sall
à quoi la peña boston les furia baki
cissé ferry à baxter damas tandis que
des noirs fuselés quoi faudrait faire
des masques bakshi dans le style des
masses de dali dans le cadre est pas
elle fait que l'on braquer des banques
est de fatick
c'est pas possible non mais j'ai
vraiment envie je pas ce que vous en
pensez mais j'ai vraiment envie
d'envoyer un arc avec le jeu tropicaux
elle préside nt pakistan urbanisation
ouais bah je pense entre vos livrets
pour halak où on va ça doit être
complètement foutu je pense pour les
blancs en fait pour les noirs pardon et
l'assomption plus mais sa fin il doit
tout connaître
karecki d'en face et je pense que tout
homme peut il laisse une fourche à neige
on va doit pas vrai un peu pâle en
remontrer nous a glissé juste près pas
là il n'y a pas grand chose depuis ça ça
va peut-être y avait des trucs à
regarder évidemment jarre est que dans
un prado salle est bon a priori non mais
ils ont d'abord quoi mais je dire voilà
est atteint il connaît plus on voit ça
est faux temps en temps c'est the bush
il semblait logique profonde piété
s'être mais il ne connaît plus ou moins
de l'ordi une colopathie d'être fou j'ai
deux quais pays il est juste une bouche
et la mettons tout sur mes choix je vais
remédier je veux des tours au sens le
retour d attendre et fois c'est tout le
temps tu restes là bas en fait ouais on
dit amadou c'était le coup le petit
module idem b4 ça ne m'a fait la dame à
2 bouge pas trop quoi avec masque un fou
ces quatre étaient 3d de aïda main aidé
à me prend à deux temps avec sa fourche
attend ses sept
when i'm ok en france tu connais pas je
vous êtes embarqué là-dedans peut-être
des c3 qui ne bloque donc s'il dit ok
ils échangent les dames et j'essaie de
tenir sa masse à medan pas par paresse
calimaq maxime steurs dans le chat with
est peut-être ça va mais c'est juste
beaucoup trop compliqué pour le jouer
donc tu as et les coûts comme dame prend
des deux qu'il faut trouver un droit de
pour trouver connaître à manon pour
hâter un fil rouge ou non on peut
laisser comme ça en vrai je faisais de
il me semble qu'un arrêt mais je n'ai
pas encore ça est gelée qui s'échangent
en rouge 5 ou gibier dragon connaît
dragonette quoi
en fait je comprends que ce soit
horrible tu fais un trou de mémoire se
finit il est rentré c'est très très dur
je pourrais je ne sais pas comment tu
agence tes pièces parce que témoin faire
des cinq poules et 7 mais évidemment
d'être champion des découvertes qu'ils
me tueraient vite il faut juste en face
rien quoi faire concept difficile pour
la chambre clou à cinq
adieu passer par du tout raciste ou quoi
pour yves à l'exo tour 1 6 1 sur l'a10
et du tour un fouet deux fois h4
l'ex bac histoire indépendant
frustrant de saint jory perd vite pour
la main à qui on ne sait pas un alors
les travellings fait que sont un peu
brusque c'est un droit de profondeur 33
la chimie calculs après là peut-être
d'autres options à vrai dire shankland
un peu un peu léger ouais ben petit
souffre avec les noirs vont hisser quoi
travailler les lignes liquidation du
club ont émis un fort non il est mise
vis de leurs jeux made by f
il a fait sortir la belle fait thème
raid d'armes à quai et avant je sais pas
je vous rappelle l'efs qui est éliminé
caruana avant de rallier par la chambre
y avait quoi la carec je pense tour
j'imagine la 4e' bloc bloc et bah
pourquoi pas
ah ben tu joues obama qui avait battu
aby nanya d'accord et je vous parle ce
n'est pas facile non je vais là-bas il
faillit gamme bien souple c'est quoi
c'est quand même bon si tu veux fonder
train va repartir à 8 je me dis je crois
que ce qu'il a joué un petit coup vers
l'arrière
elle se prendre le fond en b 5 et qui
arrivent ici faut qu'il recule sa tour à
tour celle-ci si l'on ferme vis à docce
vis à 2-1 dans la case des cinq ça se
trouve ça quand même de faire face ici
c'est donner une qualité ce qui va pas
en fait alors si ça se trouve c'est
moins pire que de se faire défoncer
allée des coûts qui sont joués mais
comme d'hab y'a un petit retard à
l'allumage mais ne coûte virginie
trouver 5 mois juste pas au parti à
tours qui lui bakhit partout hein ça va
te bien emilie pub est tournée on un
jour on est presque un jour evra en
remettre mais un jeu pourrait émettre
entre parce que là il ya moins de vivre
sur ses six du 5-5 ça pousse de tous les
côtés pour ce retour à je suis ton jeu
je pense qu'il a commencé par g5 se
situe prends tu te fais attaquer et je
vous ça ça reste en prise en vrai c'est
un bon choix pour tous racistes sur ces
six là où les troupes vont fixer tu te
dis bon qui a été de moins contre un
pion on va voir qui s'occupe de refaire
les coudes et en fait c'est automatique
je voudrais indiquer qu'ils sont
connectés et c'est le délai de
transmission en fait c'est pas quelqu'un
car la tient que ce qui a joué je rentre
le coup ça c'était à l'ancienne cantine
a été piégé en que le mec qui se
baladait latine a joué sa terre je bouge
la pièce pour que le public puisse voir
l'annoncé tout automatique juste bas
c'est non programme pouvait être
amélioré quoi dirait un rebord là je
pense qu'on est max
ce cadre
mais le chat fou des quatre noms
vous des cats fait changer changer tant
ses 5 on doit tous la bouffe et se
tourne autour 1 c'est bien tu m'aides
étrangers au pis vous faudra la bouffe
mais c'est vrai car du bim quoi qui est
bien c'est que tant qu'ils bouffent pas
le foot élite reste on s'est vite fait
rager en tout cas cet échiquier rouge
c'était le but du coloris les casques
blancs rouges
à l'époque c'est terrible c'est
magnifique c'est une très bonne idée
chantal et et a été très bon l'axé
ah c'est beau hein voilà un magnifique
franchement c'est bath harpie simple
annonce à jouer datacash 3 fêtent leurs
dix fois cette termine le truc tu vas tu
appelles 7,1 mais ce dont je crois qu'il
a fait de faim coulon ouais ça ressemble
à x 7 gers à yvan complètement nul de
vue directe gdi et oui double attaque
voilà son cahier d'exercices dauphin
chelsea sting quoi bam et attentionné
très dur enfin il est mal mais bon c'est
vrai qu'il aida poteau opposé de
résistance
en vrai trois partis noirs
sarah rang dépasser le 15e 1 non mais là
c'est là tout va dépendre de prépa
karekin il revient et le feu s'inquiète
toute l'âme post crise de pions machin
il te défoncer ouais là pour le coup
c'est peut-être une erreur a répété là
il va se prendre fou prend v8 français
ici souffrent les six truffes lâche 3 à
la fin un bon ok c'est encore un peu de
contre ja
va faire encore plus simple genre foot
français 6 sa force est chez valve prend
un goût très fouillée et tu t'en vas y
tonton et des cinq jours d'inquiétude
avant celui très simple au puy-en-velay
6 fable un trait sur fou prend pions
prends et je pense fait qu'à relief 6 et
apprendront d'élite
dans les caraïbes les trois parties
blanches costaud
c'est parfait
bravo sans que l'on en a bah écoute si
ce match a déjà gagné deux fois c'est
beaupuy bons et des méchants pas perdre
et enfin la mal embarqué il peut signer
avec la prochaine s'approche de la fin
gamin bah oui oui celle là en tout cas
après avec les blancs secs il en a gagné
deux aussi donc il peut en gagner une
troisième
jamais deux sans trois mais ça me paraît
complexe à
plus la plainte d'ong mais encore cinq
minutes après d'après la pendule autre
chose comme oui c'est vraiment un choix
en soit tu veux prendre ici puis prend
10 6 puis on dit si les ch peut-être
appris un truc je pense qu'il a pris
dans ses six mois en soucier
elle a fait un coup de recul vous
prendrez vous laisse avec sa garde le
font enfermer le font enfermer pardon
17 et maintenant peut-être tu vas ans et
z pour b5 et ses quatre mains c'est beau
bonne maîtrise le fou complètement
fermée je pense qu'il a fait ce qu'il
veut de moi c4 qui rallie à 5 en fait
réussi un bon bien sûr là c'est terrible
honnêtement je serai très tentés
d'abandonner avec les noirs je mets tes
chiens viol est un peu lié au dessus
bien ou pas sa figure lit parce qu'on
peut avoir un sable peut-être on a été
défaillant savent s'effondre y voit là
et non je laisse un peu sable alors il
est beau sable en fait c'est bien sur du
sable ont fait mais comme les tableaux
de sable quand il va te faire des petits
dessins et qui varieront ces quatre
attaques des fils et à 5
l'ordi d'un truc je lis aussi de nous
pousser cette honte et cinquième rangs
des cinq vêtements ou autres mais aussi
midi ce parchemin va bien on essaye un
peu les d'échiquier la norme et de façon
là ça y est parchemins on avait fait
pour les vieilles pertinents et c'est
encore mieux peut-être parchemin encore
plus moche
bah c'est peut-être au dessus des
attentes chacun un vraiment y deux à
temps oui nous y sommes ça c'est sûr
c'est complètement moche vernon wells a
maintenant tu penses boss wayne rooney
c'est vraiment moche dans mesrine gamme
ce terme ne choisissez de pierre loti
lens peut laisser des champions ouais ça
c'est vrai que je savais tu as déjà fait
je pense que je suis gosse je savais que
c'était terrible car on peut changer les
pièces aussi peut-être votre pire comme
pièce tient sur son port pyrénées
très belle quoi à aaa à aa
salvador et poussettes cardiaque
c'est cet aspect extraordinaire
c'est ça la regarde c'est magnifique
merci au balayage pour achever d'avant
c'est pas qu'on peut colorier tomber
ville 500 versailles c'est horrible
viens on regarde ces terribles genre
échiquier 8 bits avec pièce suite
s'annonce aussi très horrible oh ouais
mais c'est déjà mieux en fait je suis
vite fait avant la catastrophe mais ya
quand même
c'est très moche mais oui on a trop de
trucs le pire possible donc faire en 3d
et en 3d c'est ça ça a cassé truc mais
c'est terriblement nuit là j'ai pas les
cas j'aime bien ya des pièces bien un
vrai gâchis qui m'étonne je pense métal
valley avec soin
j'ai reçu que tu l'a déjà fait en fait
de son côté ça va bien ensemble ouais ça
c'est pas mal de bruit on peut regarder
comme ça qui est qualifié cette fête ça
bug 7e et des cache pas il est temps de
trois soirées pour éviter la fourchette
éventuel en f3 il peut doubler les tours
il peut toujours faire décaisser quatre
pions afin qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
ouais métal c'est pas mal en fait tu as
l'impression que c'est truqué mentez pas
ou futuristes enfin tu sais pas trop un
peu un peu qu'ils aient un peu grunge
monde apocalyptique way serait vraiment
vers les 1000 spectateurs grâce à ça non
bonjour sont à gagner
en fait tu as gagné tu es beaucoup la tv
un défi c'était de monter 2008 avec et
schering à mes pieds suite un sou est un
beau défi
artiste je reconnais pas les pièces as
tu un cavalier merde enfin ça a été
terminé appartient ya pas les genres
dans les trucs du genre est ce que tu
vois finances mais bleu est ce que c'est
le meilleur sur moi j'ai toujours bleu
j'aime bien bleu ces pièces sont pas mal
aussi bleu j'aime bien son préféré
ouf c'est le moins agressif et à la mer
de glace qui oublies aussi
wen j'utilise moi
on va faire un défi entre suis là et le
maire de graisse lequel vous préférez je
préfère le bleu mais toi comme tabous
culturels si si
bon bah ouais mais parce que tu as eu
l'habitude de l'a62 a ici c'est pour ça
que tu l'as bien des glaces qui arrive
en fait cadman c'est que mer de glace
c'est un jeu de mots en fins et
fabrication de l'est aïe si je sers
degré ça ici si on leur fait ça ici six
essais à ici comme glace ils ont fait un
jeune aux je trouve ça très manque
il est par à l'oci mais bon on rabote le
bleu classique on va pas perturber en
vrai les deux sont bien nombreux petits
boulots comme ça il est très bien très
classique à partir désolé les gars mais
juste à elle n'a aucun terrien s'est
jamais vu ça il va manger des six
et puis à 5 puis doubler les tours puis
voilà ils ces pièces sont moches son
panache un très bon peut être normal
après on peut mettre comme ça
son vernissage s'est déshabillé de
pièces ici pourquoi ces drôles de chiba
en fait c'était internet chasse cole en
fait tu as été incités face tu prononces
país et c'est enfin un français s'est
hissé en anglais du ponant ça ici ici et
à issy 6 et tu prends ce pareil donc mer
de glace ou acheter sur les néo là je
crois de pièces n'a jamais rien et au
wat classics très matrix
quelles animations je crois que les
animations les pièces se manger tout
mais c'est insupportable sait plus
comment faire
je sais pas si c'est possible ici en
fait c'est pas mon jeu de mots c'est
vraiment ce qu'ils ont fait c'était
marrant que souvent mois et sa veste
rouge
battus à avoir en fait alors si tu fais
un échec qui va se passer un truc j'ai
fait l'con intrigue le jeu pas pourquoi
mais on comprend un peu s'il se passe
des trucs
est-ce que ses analyses mais sinon ça
peut aller mais qui tous rendez un fonds
5 va faire très bons voeux il a fait
tourner je pense est temps qu'il y ait
quand même hâte feu d'artifice tant
qu'on ira où l'on me cogne à un matt
c'est la folie poids ouais c'est vrai
qu'en vrai s'est pas départi serait
intéressante aujourd'hui c'est bizarre
ça se passe rien et 1
as tu vas y avait déclaré qu' un éclair
il est parti comme un fou
non mes chèques se reprendre un éclair
françois jean prouvé ici on va pas avoir
le match quoi ya pas pour la c1 qui a
fait flamber 6 pour le mater des huit
fromages ainsi les coûts la gare allez
petit éclair pour être dark sidious quoi
en fait même si tu fais un match là ça
va pas le faire comme ça ma valise
dommage car il aurait mieux fait d'avoir
ce niveau contre maxime à bagnolet un
bon niveau il mène au score un patron
d'une petite pub
ah ben ça repart triki a pas une seule
nul dans ce match ouais mais les partis
sont pas rassasiés new sapeurs même et
j'ai en fait c'est juste un carnage
ces carnages ray pour attendre dix
minutes 1 ces diminutions garde jusqu'à
la prochaine ah ben oui qui part
les petites minutes type app et tracking
qui va aller en demies sûrement là j'ai
du mal à voir chaque land revenir la
chambre là les deux touches mal quand
même de perdre comme ça deux fois la
chance
plus tu m'en voudront terrassé quoi
malheureusement pour ce chancre oui oui
et je pense que je fais au cfa car ici
c'est très bien pour feu ne servent pour
grecque fait d'abord de la même
nationalité je pense que il doit
apprendre enfin je pense qu'eric l'insee
limousin est complètement nul fait au cf
mais je veux pas l'essayer neeson contre
un tel jeu doit nuire
bon bah bravo cardiaque sur ton de
candidat en fin très inattendu mais pas
très surprenant parce que hier tu
attends pas qu'ils reviennent en fait si
ça arrive tu dis pas qu'il est possible
mais on l'avait un peu oublié
c'était dit elle un peu mis les échecs
de côté parce que bon il faut autre
chose il aimait sa finale de championnat
du monde est très lié avec petit jardin
ouais après savais qu'avec toute
l'énergie de poutine vlad
il peut aller très loin torse nu coup à
fond au torse nu devant s'achever
allaient tous
ouais terrible aksar qui demandent ces
chèques sacem de bio les matches ces
camions et staff un ballet ctp aux deux
places et plein de bo de en fait il est
là le truc c'est qu'ils ont déjà fait un
partout enfin notre bureau de du coup
ils ont fait un partout la met au fond
elle apprend il ya 1 0 on ignore ce que
le parquet qui ne s'est pas tout à fait
vrai en fait je vous encourage cathy
aussi de la réussite cardiaque mais
après ils étaient impressionnants au
spotlight le match était chaud en fait
cai chine il a juste fait la serrure
totale avec les noirs de fermer bien et
que les blancs il essayait un peu
c'était serré serré et puis à maxime
cadence un peu plus rapide et les seuils
le d4 qui est ces trois systèmes je bave
à une partie compliquée et saccharine
pour sa session de fond prend 1,4
attendu quoi il se trouve c'est pas
mauvais mais après ils trouvent tous les
coups de défense mais 6-0 défense rod
est possible aussi coiffé la gueule du
coup après là il a juste été très bon en
défense et après qu'on ait pu être le 3
tout ça c'était dur quand même hein
c'est pas près d'avoir fait une grosse
partie après
cada partout et se passe quoi ils refont
deux matches voir à un moment quand ça
fait trop de un partout ils font plus
qu'une dernière partie qu'on appelle
l'armageddon
donc c'est une partie dans laquelle les
blonds un peu plus de temps sur qu'ils
ont cinq minutes les morts quatre
saisons 6 et noir 5 je sais pas ce que
ça leur règle ici est par contre les
blancs doivent gagner
merci à partie nulle suis calé noire va
être qualifiés mais davantage d'avoir
une ligne de plus talent et blanc
toujours en premier donc tu vas un peu
plus la pression est donc à la fin de
partie il y aura forcément un risque car
hacking gagner cette compétition il sera
champion du monde et non basée aux
appellations en fait on ne peut rien
du monde non c'est pour savoir qui est
pas si mal mais bon je prends toujours
les blancs ont nargué nombre de mandats
alors bonne question je n'ai pas eu
souvent à jouer ce genre de trucs moins
cela dit
neymar faux j'ai fait j'ai pris les
blancs bah ça dépend des banques qui tu
joues aussi la dynamique du match etc
mais c'est vrai que de jouer avec les
blancs tu joue vite tu met un peu la
pression machin c'est pas mal après si
c'était eu du mal dans le match avant
avec les blancs que tu sais que tu
obtiens rien c'est peut-être mieux de
jouer pour faire nul avec les noirs donc
ça dépend aussi de qui tu as en face
comme en match ouais je pense pas qu'une
réponse car il commenté dans champion du
monde en fait il ya un vrai 6 pour le
championnat du monde pilotes qualifiés
tels fameux tournoi des candidats qu'on
avait commenté en avril dernier qui aura
lieu en avril l'an prochain on sait pas
trop mais on y investit on imagine en
avril donc ça tourne bien qu'il faut
gagner pour aller défier le champion du
monde en match
bio 12 14 à 14 changent et changent tout
le temps mon fab et que c'était pas
assez douces partis n'ont besoin de 24
est trop humide ont fait 40 ans partie
que si j'ai trouvé que le match
précédent était trop long en vrai alors
pas trop long dans le temps que ça
durera en fait et beaucoup de nuls
le match était fermé et du coup ils ont
dit oui mais les firmes qui a passé deux
parties n'avait que douze 0,74 live
vraiment bien fait all in
ça change la vie c'est un petit peu
l'ont enfin vous les parties étaient
ennuyeux ce qui est beaucoup de nuls et
donc c'était long pour le public à
regarder et donc pour régler ce problème
on est passé de 12 à 14 c'est vraiment
plus jeunes
en fait ils trouvent pas le diagnostic
que ce soit long il y brosse êtres eux
mais du coup on va rallonger pour que ce
soit moins long une autre idée pour
raccourcir le match c'était de mettre
les départage avant même son
exceptionnel talent je comprends l'idée
mais j'aime pas envie
sous l'appellation couple n'est pas
impropre vainqueurs de coupe n'est
jamais un champion a envoyé non c'est un
problème c'est le foot cela coupe du
monde de foot tu es champion du monde
est en fait vu que le foot c'est le
sport principal est que ça parle à tout
le monde
tu dis à baguer les coups nous on est
champion du monde alors que c'est vrai
que quand il fait la coupe de france
battez pas chômé oui mais avait juste
faut changer faut changer le monde quoi
non mais là le problème c'est pas pour
moi le problème je me répète une 10e
fois c'est quand m si tu enlèves les
places qualificatives aux candidats tu
peux garder l'appellation coupe du monde
mais le fait que se sont joints
qualificatif c'est ça le problème pour
moi sinon tu peux l'appeler super que
nokia ou touche pas tu t'en fous dumas
n'ont pas peu importe en fait mais
celui-là il est un peu j'ai peur qu'on
l'appelle votre fonds d'un service un
peu marketing des gens qui réfléchissent
mais peu importe mais c'est vrai que
coupe du monde ça porte à confusion
en vrai - c'est enlever les places
qualificatives me répète mais là le truc
c'est que c'est un coualy fire en plus
est sur le chemin pour devenir champion
du monde donc c'est très bizarre
vas-y toi un bunker de couche-tard ses
gammes bon tournoi tu es content de
gagner
on était surtout content tu te qualifies
candidats ça qui est dommage c'est qu'en
fait la qualif prend pas sur le fado
ministre uc et coup c'est biaisé
sachant que là il est très nerveux et
fait que marcher il tourne un peu en
rond comme les fruits du monde car tu as
des méta beaucoup de gens au départ de
tous les pays
ouais mais t'as pas les meilleurs par
l'attaqué à cinq est venu jouer mais en
fait il manque les numéros 2 3 4 5
mondial mata 22 août un tel carnage mais
oui c'est vrai que tu peux nous pas
votre action man en vue les rapides et
où tu peux y taille padiglione déjà
alors qu'il a il a gagné finaliste je
crois un peu par ronnie enfin mon heat
et l'empattement
ok t'as pas d'epo mais bon on va juste
titre les placards bon y'a passe au raja
pas gagné la dernière d'ailleurs il
manque du monde pour pour une world cup
quoi à la chan après ils ceux qui
refusaient aussi alors à devenir si vous
voulez comme on disait les mecs déjà
qualifiés ils ont pas trop endettés afin
disons surtout dépôt du post justifia
mine pourtant celui d'avoir préparé son
match il peut pas partir trois semaines
les bonnes non les vannes il jouait il
se fait éliminer au premier tour par à
chuck bass ont joué la baby gym à l'une
des quatre îles des jeux tous les vols
n'a pas joué mais trek a joué un mail à
jouer son premier coup des quatre dans
une surprise
dommage qu'il veut chez 400 étaient
mauvais grob
il avait de la fièvre m a alors appris
et quand même beaucoup de gens qui
jouent avec de la fièvre quand même un
fab moi ça m'est déjà arrivé avec de la
fia mais je suppose que rognon il aurait
joué enfin peut-être qu'il appelle le
droit de jouer à cause de la fièvre qui
est un protocole dans sa chambre je sais
pas en fait je sais pas à quel point il
se sentait mal et si la 41e fièvre ou 38
c'est pas pareil aussi quoi c'est vrai
mais évidemment tout le monde a déjà
joué malades 28
ah oui non mais c'est normal d'ailleurs
au tennis des fois les mecs qui tu vois
il joue avec des bandages ils ont des
trucs qui sinon les ampoules y aille
jouer quoi ton pire ils comprennent bien
que est pas venu jouer à cause d'une
petite grippette
d'ailleurs il ya peu de communication
officielle sur ce qu'il avait vraiment
quoi on ne sait pas mort il m'aura pas
dit a joué avec de la fièvre arrêt non
mais tu peux jouer avec de la fia le
sait les bonnes qui n'a pas souhaité
participer un nom mais après peut-être
que c'était bien pour pas contaminer
d'autres c'était une bonne décision je
sais pas enfin et du coup un peu importe
à son sa santé des joueurs ont pilonné
là-dessus alors il s'est fait éliminer
au tennis il a été dans le tableau et
j'allais là ses parois le cover non
c'est important de le préciser
il a perdu quoi oui mais il n'est pas
forfait 1
j'espère que ça va compter pour le vélo
quand même ah bah non si tu as passé
comme tu veux te refais que tu viens pas
le vertige doit annoncer avant quand
j'étais en voiture et un accident à mes
entraîneurs je tu perds pas de poids non
plus tu perds des points nodaux que tu
es dans la salle et que tu as joué un
coup genre tu joues ton téléphone qui
sonne à merde amat a perdu des points
mais si tu viens pas tu ne savais pas ça
tu vois bonjour non mais enfin je
conditions genre de protection 100 m tu
peux te retirer il aurait pu aller voir
l'arbitré je me retire la barre mais je
pense en fait qu'il espérait aller mieux
le lendemain visible serait menée 1 0 ch
0 puis le lendemain sans nature pas bien
il fait bon bah je joue pas du tout il
avait quoi du coup bah disons il lui dit
qu'il a dit quelque chose après tu
c'est sûr que la valeur de base il
aurait été content de jouer était en
forme et l'a gagné dernier magnus
tourner et puis retrouver une bonne
forme donc c'est sûr qu'il avait un truc
mais ça c'est quelque chose dont il est
sorti au premier tour porte n'est pas
venue en russie pour prendre l'avion et
repartir
donc fawcett allez vas y avoir croqué
des 4 way c'est théorique un pote être
un problème en hérisson à venir ouais
c'est peut être bien pour jean claude
lavigne hay river voici ton cellectis
c'est quoi ton site ici de quoi c'est
que nous avions peur et on s'y tissent
belge faisait pas bon ce faire un gîte
sans moi je tourne et c'est bien quoi
faire un gîte
je sais pas ce que c'est une tour si
need is what is to see this c'est une
angine une angine
ah bah voilà peut-être que c'était
vraiment une angine de l'angine blanche
sylvie sesena les amygdales défoncé un
mur à l'aide ça tu peux jouer avec un de
base mais bon moi j'ai déjà joué avec
une angine lycées 6 en tête la dame mais
bon impression assénant une forte ou pas
aussi
les attaques et les logiques garde la
colonne des ouverte pour mettre une
petite tour piqué c'est trop extérieur
renonce à être un peu modérer son
les marinades jean-claude ne gagne pas
d'ailleurs c'est un bon signe parce et
même s'il fait mieux pour la gagne et ce
alors allé aussi loin c'est pas facile
il avait fait quoi dessine quand je
crois de zynga non ce que la raison
qu'en dehors des ouvertures il est
vraiment pas en dessous shankland
dernier deux fois avec les points et
jason qui se défend même bien quand il
est mal non mais je crois que
l'ouverture se fait vraiment la
différence niveau par niveau elle a dit
la version sata le plus important c'est
le contraire du bas niveau jérémy 900 et
1300 l'ouverture ça vaut vraiment
quasiment rien et à 2700 2800 c'est
vraiment le plus important car et qui ne
passe en demie j'aurais canton
compatriote fedoseyev et de l'autre côté
du tableau c'est carmen contre duda
s'assurer déjà russe aux candidats oui
par deux un an et demi un bon dessin qui
prend le centre après ray kay ses trois
tours d un ça arrive
bon c'est pas grand chose pour les
blancs évidemment genre truc mais ils
espèrent pouvoir mettre ses tours au
centre qui un échange et d'amd 8 sont un
peu mal à l'aise et aussi si on compare
les pièces qui sont un peu tout pareil
le fou j'ai deux parcours fawcett c'est
mieux c'est pas beaucoup mieux mais même
deux russes n'auront pas suffi la
dernière fois ci puisque n'est pas gagné
mais andré qui joue pour une équipe donc
je sais dire que ça c'est vous c'est
leur marque puissante mais aussi book
trois fois trois fois oui il y en a deux
qui ont servi à rien tu auras un rôle
pour yannick noah autour d un attaque la
dame
nommé vite et dames francesca traiteur
d'élite a l'air solide c'est bien
symétrique
alors stéphane l'idée quand c'est comme
ça c'est je serais cassé 6 des six
essais d'avancé et b pour défiler les 15
ha non c'est pas si simple à réaliser
genre bozic doner kebab belle partie du
coup bah oui c'est très bien c'est un
maxi à bien bien que bonne corpulence
tu peux recommander je peux recommander
vraiment très très faim saint cloud qui
réfléchit mais la cour est contre car
yak sûr toujours de position c'est mais
déjà de terreur je pensais aussi qu'il
avait jamais gagné
la catalane petit moka qui attire tout
reprendre et il a fait un retour d'un v8
airs doctorants des huit mois d'affaires
de l'essuie-glace excès d'amour elle
sera bien sûr il ya un connaisseur nous
arrachent leur ai dit qu'ils veulent
près du marché grand buteur
et vous quel silane non je vois comment
s'appellent les délices à rien c'est
l'autre ont commandé par l'adq m
ouais ça ne joue pas le fast food et non
content mais bon mais en fait le soir
ils sont peut-être plus là ils sont au
moins un fast food il faut que la vie
n'y a aucun combat le soir d'écouter un
peu lestes tu veux plus avoir la la
bouffe premium donc des sens un petit
peu mais quand même qu'il reste dans un
dans un mètre choix et de qualité quoi
midi était vraiment pas mal à côté du
marché forville vraiment bien là le hic
c'est bien très bien le petit italien
très bien ça échange comme c'est ça
faire damer fuite
clairement un niveau différent
d'implication il me semble et champlan
de plus travailleur que tarentule que
talentueux ni marty mcfly ouais mais bon
après les ouvertures c'est pas que du
travail et du talent c'est aussi d'avoir
les grosses secondes en écart yakine en
a des millions tu peux tu des bonnes
machines et tout ça dans mes shankland
nom au bas du projet de la définir mais
que c'était moins précis moins profond
moins que je suis peut-être pas veut
travailler travailler travailler mais à
un moment donné s'il ya des gens paient
assez s'arrête à une thibaut courtois
salle tu peux pas comblé un ouais bah tu
es ce que tu peux
autour des 1
cette dame 8 août a réfuté sur bar est
vrai que je pensais de base les têtes
qui vivent à 31,5 quand même pour
déstabiliser de cavaliers et course à
s'incruster ou 1 tour 17 ou équivalent
et ou 4 cette dame avait dû comme ça sur
scène à cannes est à quai les 5 à 17 ans
rec ou tissus un peu karine ces
marchands cloud c'est vrai ici enfin
savait pas ces problèmes d'ouverture
c'est vrai que dans le jeu il n'est pas
derrière ça va enfin et pas forcément
devant mais ni road rio5 hockey - lna
toussaint à la turbie n'est pas content
avec le truc le plus logique non il y
prendra me prend il te dit de faire dame
2 c'est déjà la dame elle exposé puis je
défends ton foot je vais faire une pique
et les cinq ans disons qu'il s'en aille
en faire un petit dames c'est cette
hockey 5 puis ok mais cinq bouge
sinko et la petite case décide
finalement tôt ou tard elles arrivent et
tu prends un petit avant qu un avantage
un avantage ok faut qu'ils trouvent tous
à la chambre par l effet de mode direct
direct jean clade bon en fait d'armes
était après je peux comprendre
de vastes je dis bah je vais pas les
déranger sa dame b vide qui bloque sa
tour juste tulle est pas vraiment vu que
tu as des idées de découvertes etc
mais on soit d'un média est bien sûr
mais le truc c'est que tu l'acier prend
fou prend et e5 surtout on va voir si le
fait face à jouer à l'écran le sing cola
va être fort équivalent epr en france il
fait 5 ça peut être relou symétrie après
avantage fut le temps des cinq tomes et
moi pas carrément des siècles
très beau c est clair qu elle vraiment
une très belle suggestions cette
animation cas c'est très dommage que ce
soit pas du blitz quoi ça va beaucoup
plus vite sans et dangereuse en tutu
mais c'est pas du beau style de jeu dans
ces parties fager que ça envoie pas
comme le match de maxime on a vraiment
eu des partis spectaculaire c'est
vraiment en fond de court par rame quoi
well as et deux rameurs ses ventes et
les blancs au curry kinshasa réseau les
paraphes donc être un coup de raquette
web services est tombé 4 je tiens rouge
bugs des richesses comme aujourd'hui on
sabote beaucoup quand même rendre le
chic & fung ma force à 3 français 3 d'un
procès 300 france trop comme ça
moncef si c'est en fait je pense je
prendrais pas je garderai la perte fou
oui assez faible non je pense aux prises
en fait c'est pas fait bouger prenait
alors je sais pas ce que tu fais du dame
b 2 tu veux juste on fout comme détroit
pourquoi pas un territoire de 8 et puis
tu essayes de jeunes final ça mais tu as
raison on attaque la tour invitons car
ça va mais
à la fin il a tout à ruth en l'air mais
c'est avantage quand même long terme
pour change la whey il peut revenir il
peut recoller chrome 6 5 j'ai ma
décision
ça va être juste ça non c'est marrant
quand même très moisis sion cardiaque
jeu l'attachement attendait ce qui fait
en la porte facilement avec les noirs et
finalement vote chez bud de titres trop
qui va défendre facile quoique tu en
sais pas si m fuchs pris la dame point
ils attaquent la tourisme et du funk du
bon coin mf5 pays bas c'est de faire de
jivan final four en es tu t'arraches 5
est ok mais comment une ouverture des
quatre tours à jeter loin comme ça tadam
eu quatre hommes de sylvain roux tout je
crois pas au vote on va voir ça se
trouve c'est un bon choix car il va
réagir
tout est très fort et je juge mais
vraiment d'avis et du client chez sing
sing tao ya tout étudié tu les prends
coup c'est tu les prends quand ces cours
fab les killers assisting trouve jamais
je suis pas sûr
ça te motive pas non mais c'est
peut-être très bien pour des gens
motivés
c'est pourquoi il a pris et ça va être
chaud bateaux régatent ces chiens en
fait vous allez voir ça va arriver sur
l'échiquier gelé la semaine peuvent être
si on met ça refait tout le guet donc on
est obligé d'attendre là on arrive là il
est rare tour des quatre tours j'ai 4 1
mais là il est mieux que l'an passé
l'alsacien évident que je prends pas
comme une chute qui s'enclenche tir et
égalise incroyable non mais dame est
rens et du coup tour des quatre
sucreries
enfin si vous la poursuite future à
tours jumelles de 323
ok ok j'ai en fait je suis trois un truc
comme ça à chaque fois non pas tout de
suite non mais en fait ça va tourner et
on ferait d'hommes j'ai cinq échecs et
au rejet qui entraînerait non mais
thorzain et ont pas autant g4 à temps il
faut réfléchir à comment passer cette
tour non en fait sa large victoire des
katas sont ce qu'on veut faire et
l'attaqué est à son va là-bas pour ses
huîtres raison dun g5 ont fait échec on
défendra que c'est un fait on a bandé
417 profite d'être d'ailleurs on peut
faire tourner des scènes dans tous les
cas est un principe au régime d'alger 5
on est vraiment sûr de le faire j'aime
bien posé la question à des
regroupements champions ça se voit lire
si je vais le défoncer pour 17 c'était
pas un dégoût qu'on pense à nous pour sa
tournée 4 mg 5 je pense sont envoyés en
éclaireurs et va voir quoi changer
il joue très vite champ clos quand même
un peu trop pour ce coup là qui étaient
peut-être parce qu'il est encore humide
là il frétille 6,8 et d'alger-centre
c'est cette femme a fait pas en fait
t'es qu'un peu tout je me serais
indirecte mais je veux être comptable
c'est un peu des pions hurricanes les
cinq mois chez dams et si ce mouvement
du famsi h4 ternir un peu tout partout
où tu vois quoi well as tu es noir ils
ont plus trop de coûter très cher jouer
notre quart et qui ne peut bien faire
dorer fitr qui libère sa dame prend b3
comme ces quatre juste du défunt ouais
charles à partir à tout moment
c'est chaud et a du coup le chat là ça
vient d'où je vends de foot
pourquoi bah c'est pas à sainté c'est
celle là est un norvégien qui a ramené
socle de son club
ensuite à rosenborg un peu le champ
d'après-match conti qu'anti quand ils
gagnent ext heureux quoi donc il a il a
importé ça mais là je suis pas je pense
qu'ils font plus en fait depuis que j'ai
mon équipe donc dans notre crinière mais
c'était nouveau
vraiment il faisait pas suivre la
pression ses doigts 25
1 4 à 4 le wisla problème le problème
c'est le roi faible en fait pour les
noirs et les colonnes et 1 va de la tour
aussi qui n'active pas qu'un instant et
fuite à rien faire après mais sur
l'instant rien n'est emprise
mais blanc est peut-être tu peux faire
un petit h 4 h de un moment pour pas
trop d'échecs mais c'est pas simple à
gagner bien sûr le moment tu dis assez
peu vague
lise roy faible mais mobile je crois
pourtant g4 pourquoi pas autour des 4
qui reviendrait tout à fait c'est une
idée mais le truc c'est davantage là ils
sont cool quand on voit pas comment les
noirs peuvent égaliser en fait que tu
fais des coûts toujours longtemps tue
même à l'otan tuent le presse purée on a
peut-être fait une connerie tu portes
une tactique et tu gagnes pas tu y
croies la légalisation de jean claude
hamel l île et ouais je pense qu'il a
une bonne chance de gagner 70 80 % non
merci je pense sytral pour 2007
être surmontées l'orangé set mais j'ai
pas trop pourquoi attendre un coup c'est
terrible pour karim et fort ce qu'ils
jugent toutefois là avec les noix à la
prochaine champions à la faut qu'ils
changent vraiment un bape est refusé
pour coop entre petrov ça peut être une
idée je fais un truc faut qu'ils
connaissent tu fais n'est vraiment rien
à connaître et quads damas huit voix
dessus
bon je vais faire tourner toutefois
changé ma vie de six poussif comme un
problème pratique
bon peut-être comme des deux juste un
début de tour des huit attaques h 6 rue
morin c'est ça que je veux dire c'est
vraiment fort mais c'est pas très dur
c'est le premier auquel j'ai pensé aussi
parce que tu veux tarifs et dames c'est
un choc l'a vite
copie que ce que pierre arditi tort
d'être à vue car aucune chance vient de
lille et je fais salaire quand on
condamne ses propres comme des deux
shows en votre pain c'est la pression
c'est le stress c'est le point s 1 je
veux dire dépotage des deux ils
voulaient me des dames c'est 8
ouais mais tu occultes à tour jean vergé
gâte rien calculé
mais bon parfois quand tu calcules et il
change le tour de france 3
c'est pas s'ils pensent encore à le
gagner ou pas il reste assez confiant un
petit dam des cinq ex ministre de la
défense tu regardes il se prend les
mains derrière le dos pour pas jouer
vite ça 3dans prendre le train ouais en
fait si bien en pro qui truste deux
nouveaux échecs 60 kg au ça va ça va
qualifier que des belles défenses de
cardiaque mais il a montré des signes de
fébrilité quand même ouais bon dans le
jeu
jean claude qui pourra s'en rendre aux
endroits les doigts et pas que des packs
e et pas que les doigts c'est pas grand
chose à vivre a convié cinq intersaison
plus orageux te faire des trucs non ces
avantages blanc encore un
je pense que c'est de mettre la dame /
decca tenons un truc qui est bien c'est
que les plombs ils ont jamais b53 pions
prend fin la taille fait d'un homme
influent dams qui attendent demain
adam f 4g pas faire dan des huit cantons
à celle des seuils je pense c'est le
mieux qu'il puisse faire non ce qu'il a
fait quattro un volant mais soulage que
tron s'est bien passé ça peut mettre en
place leurs enfants des réseaux de maths
nouveau tenté et en plus tu iras je
travaille tôt raconté échec et tu te
barres un peu quoi mais cela 10 h contre
eupen amsellem cinq lots d'objets 4 way
était le fameux dam dom l'après talent 3
contre 2 qui doit être nul mais bon tu
as la jouer allez vous faire acheter
capte son que d'autres n'y fait j 4 vous
allez kg 3 ce même genre de coups ouais
c'est le même genre d'idée
dame b 4 bombes à
souad hamdar saddam 17 2004 justement
très bien en dix-sept vite les baies 5
hir et tu défends ton pions
on perd
et peut-être 11 est d'alger cadre d'un
projet quatre ans j'ai quatre des cinq
si on prend réf grafite incidents et fit
wii mais des dangers tout va c'est dire
si j'ai engagé mon père même s'il est
bon tiens il faudrait peut-être dans le
carré mais nous dit qu'il faut envoyer
washington ap renvoyer p6 b 7 h 6 h
cette dame et assurera je suis sûr et
chaque peinture et lequel je veux parler
on gagne et on gagne
risque il n'y a pas une diagonale de la
mort la dame des deux dames à schwyz et
diagonale à vrai dire parce que ça
ressemble à perpète malheureusement six
jours à part par là un baisser les coûts
jeûneurs je crois dans machete qu'il
n'avait pas le schéma dans six courts
c'est terry moi j'avais dans un cours
d'eau dash-8 ouais j'avais un exercice
comme ça que tu aurais dû tout petits à
perpète de base parce que en fait le
père pète ces dames 1 et d'amal je suis
trop tour et tu oublies en fait elle est
grand que d'hommes vers l'arrière sont
durs avoir conduit facilement que cela
fermé nos si tu vas être obligé de
repartir par là il va perdre h2o mieux
vivre se vengera sur b 6 mai et ce sera
mort à faire grève de roy evans est sage
de 80 n'a pas le choix en fait vous
allez le voir bientôt sur l'échiquier
arrive à prendre h2 du coup il va faire
d'amnéville 3g cette dame prend b6 mélo
d'objets les objets en plus t'as même
pas ça donc c'est complètement ya plus
racheté il ya plus de jeu c'est la
position taissy annoncé la pose d'un
entonnoir banon
je prie officier du tranquille car sinon
ce qu'on regarde à mach 2 détient
affichée par des échecs
autre hommage de chemin des états d'âme
ses trois des cinq est ce que c'est pas
c'est à dire d'un match je ne peux pas
récupérer p6 batteuse faire du hb -
c'était bien le week-end du coup pareil
c'est logique
bonjour un calcul et mais juste de visu
hadji s'adonnant à vibrer
vois pas comment comment champion de la
somme de ça à faire le point mon fab à
la jambe et si son fils a depuis vous
fait dame j'ai cinq échecs et je sais
pas quoi et vous êtes l'attenté après un
métier et on fait quoi on vient on sait
d'où ça peut durer des plombes encore
fab
[ __ ] tu t'appelles menace non mais là
c'est rendu que tu perds tu te résigne
finul ok j'ai perdu c'est pas facile à
arrêter là laventure l'histoire le
révérend des 3 limite de me prouver 6
vite la finale jeudi à l'ats carine
multitude de coups un jour dame b
d'auchan le fait d'amener le corps bien
même il aurait aidé à me rendre ici
c'était complètement nul oui ça sera
encore à deux pas mal de tête à tête un
petit pied jeu sur d'amd 5 pourrait
changer toute la finale est le père
enfin bien sûr mais peut-être peur
peut-être elle fait d'amd 4
et marche arrière en fait par un désert
jeudi en visite je fais rien joué pour
le moment
jade à l'euro à pois le pont de beure
fait tout le temps et est seul qui peut
espérer c'est échanger les dames de
france et donc je sais sa place à l'idée
vous montez le roi allez donc
essaye de faire
dans la 3
4 on tire au g7 de retour un truc s'il
devait juste éviter les changes des arts
avec les noirs et ça va bientôt se
terminer normalement les amis quattro
qui nous aiment pas la pendule en fait
ce truc intéressant à voir est là c'est
encore pire
sept cas monsieur way au moins on peut
voir si le japon d'une un jour loin de
là
allez à prendre tous les risques pour
monter le roi et puis voir un jean simon
johnson a mené 5-1 alors dame b3 dam des
trois pardon complexe on peut être
complexe à 32 secondes de jeu sont ni
très large il ya disons non plus par
coup franc sur derrière tu veux prendre
prendra j'essaie 3d 3g ça doit être bon
pied et frans batterie carrière c'est
que s'ils encaissent encore f3 bon
moment on se fait beaucoup de réflexions
et échanges les dames ça gagner enfin
certes elle encore un espoir là
maintenant je pense qu'avec il devait
même finir par y gagner en fait ouais à
l'autopsié nul l'on veut trouver design
shankland bombe a beau match entre
langue bien battu mais parfois la haute
la marche était trop haute fab et donc
ces cars yakine très kimsufi pour les
deux niveaux de maxime
on y vit bourreau de la chanteuse
sachant que là il lui reste sur sa route
fedoseyev est peut-être en finale s'il
souhaite gagner cette finale contre carl
scène peut-être un dernier beau match
j'espère que vous avez qui fait ses
petits rapides on a pas vraiment eu de
belles parties à vrai dire non à la
dernière un peu sympa 20 ans où il y
avait un intérêt envers tient peut-être
à revenir ou quoi mais c'est ça que
karine là ce match et les deux fois
sinon oui ça qui est plutôt des
deathmatchs après un parti aussi s'est
terminé de manière étonnante
wen a réfléchi mais il s'est pris une
tactique donc cette partie qui est un
peu un rythme un peu étrange mais cette
future carrière sa fille quelques peurs
par trois semaines de position ce
concept peser dans les jambes et le
match dès le jour de repos va lui faire
du bien demain donc un grand merci
d'avoir suivi et on se retrouve dimanche
pour la suite des aventures
merci à tous